two
what is uh it is Friday September 30th
it's Friday baby
yes sir
uh today's episode sponsored by
hellofresh just as a reminder before we
talk about this
I want to get some things out real fast
before I forget next Monday or this
coming Monday we'll not have a podcast
because it's mining Ila's 10-year
anniversary
yeah
so we'll be we'll be busy on that day
but um but I will say for members for
our lovely appreciated uh fantastic
members there will be a Tuesday episode
up wow
and I think I've been reported on our
getaway oh maybe you can even share fine
yeah
[Music]
so yeah so members will get an episode
on Tuesday thank you to you guys
um of the of the see you next Tuesday
but other than that no podcast Monday
and that's all I wanted to say at the
top of the show before I forgot Ela whoa
I feel like Roger Rabbit when he comes
out in his eyeballs
yeah you look good thank you
you walked in Alina was like I just Lena
scared me because she's like oh my God I
wish I recorded it and like I I don't
record my life but that's the moment I
wish I was recording yeah I'm still in
shock
just a totally different look I love it
thank you so much but I was like well
Lena's like oh my God you look so amazed
and I was like whoa what happened what
did I miss did Ela bring a present for
Lena or something but no it's very sweet
it was very sweet the way you were
acting lovely how are you feeling um
I love it as the new it's fun I just
like ELO point oh it completely was not
on my radar to do this and then you just
said that you liked this look and I was
immediately like that's what I'm doing
and now I really like it I just when my
regular hair I feel so boring I feel
like a boring person and it's not I
don't know it it's just myself that's
just how I feel so like this makes me
feel do it excited
and also I like dressing up when my hair
is like interesting in fact whatever I
wear becomes like a statement or
something so it's fine you know it's a
little different than the last time
because the last time was more like
blonde yeah
like bleached out but this time it looks
more like Gray
it's just it kind of comes out different
every time because of how the hair
reacts because it's like I start so dark
interesting uh so this time I guess last
time after I bleached my hair and went
colors then I dyed it back to Brown
so this time those parts didn't really
bleach completely all the way off okay
so we had to do like toner like three
times or something okay yeah you guys
were going from like what what hours are
you guys going from it's insane how long
it takes to do that so long from like
started at 9am
and we weren't done by like 6 37 in the
evening
so yeah
just wait almost like close to 12 hours
I guess dude what almost like nine hours
is that how long it takes if you go to
like a salon and do that you're there
for nine [ __ ] hours Sammy's nodding
really mine mine was from nine and I
didn't leave until seven o'clock and
this is the same person until seven oh
you used the same girl yeah yeah
so you went to her salon
oh my god dude yeah what do you do in a
salon for nine hours we became besties
right you just talked the whole time it
was great chop it up yeah it's hard it's
so hard to just sit in one place for the
whole day it's like a mini torture
honestly
so is that so is that like a common
experience women just go sit in the
salon for nine hours you ever do that
Lena yeah not really
I don't think I've ever been there that
long
um when I did my highlights it was like
four or five hours but yeah and then
that's just for highlights like sat on
my phone right highlights is like
because you have really dark hair like
uh Ela does I guess if you died at all
it would probably take that long right
well if you're going from dark to light
it takes forever and especially like to
do it in a healthy way yes you would
want it to take longer rather than
shorter so yeah Ela had one guy come to
the house who has been finding your
[ __ ] hair started falling out bro you
kicked them out it's the first time it
took 12 hours my hair still fell off and
it didn't even get it to look like I
wanted it it was still like too yellow
than than what I had wanted
bro it was getting weird because like
they started super early yeah and then I
was there with the kids and it started
to be like 12 o'clock and I'm like this
is getting like midnight to leave
past midnight is becoming one o'clock I
was like listen guys you guys need to
wrap this up because this is way too
[ __ ] late yeah that was wild man
wait so how much does it cost you for
like a nine hour service because that
that's got to be expensive I mean
they're spending their whole day it's
just one client for the whole day yeah
it is expensive it's about like
um 1200.
women be shopping boy wait is that how
much you spend Sarah no how much was
yours
um well it depends yeah it just depends
I mean it depends on what like their
hourly rate is and how hard it's going
to be to do like
what you want but mine was going from
black and if I were to go like hilo's
color it would have taken it would have
been like double the cost and taken
twice as long so so what how much did it
cost
um you don't have to save it I don't
want to say is it that bad wow Mine Mine
I thought was very fair I didn't think
it was that bad does Ian know how much
you spent
I don't know I don't think so would you
be shocked if it was like 500 bucks
because that's like a feak of fish bro
it's a process I don't know my hair is
super healthy still and she did an
amazing job so it was it was worth all
of it also the red has been a absolute
uh showstopper I'm also doing like uh
I'm in L.A and I'm having someone come
to my house you know so I'm oh you got
that premium service premium for that
right I'm sure you can get stuff done
for Less yeah you could be basically
just wanted to go put roll out a
sleeping bag for her put out a blanket
and pillow
by the time she leaves
um well anyway Ela looks awesome
uh by the way a b got his wisdom teeth
out yesterday so he's not here
oh uh how's he doing
here today yeah
people are saying it could be 200 it
could be 400
it's a whole range
oh uh thank you to Matthew terwin he
gave I don't know what this means 350s
are
South African money how much is 350Z
it's like uh 20 bucks oh thank you
Matthew please buy yourselves an
anniversary drink on me
we've oh he says me and my wife just
celebrated our anniversary we feel like
we've aged with you guys also this hair
is amazing well thank you man thank you
Matthew
legendary maps to you guys my wife went
off for pizza without me yes yes
um Olivia's still gone obviously we know
that
um
but we have a video of baby I told
I said guys you have to get a video of
ab all [ __ ] up on the uh
anesthesia
and I think we got a pretty good video I
mean it was definitely entertaining now
how soon after the surgery was this
recorded Lena as we were leaving the
parking lot so this was fresh right yeah
I had because I couldn't record him so I
handed him my phone and I said the
camera
was he causing a ruckus in the
office at all no he was very calm but
very like silly
um as we were walking out because he was
dizzy and he had to like kind of hold on
to me as we were walking and then we
were getting onto the um and the stairs
and he was like messing around like
leaning over the
um the ramp he's like oh I was trying to
scare me like he's gonna throw it all
over
um so yeah it made me feel better too
because I was really worried about him
and the fact that he was able to like be
joking already made me feel better sure
I remember when I got my wisdom teeth
out
I was in a goofy silly mood too when I
came out of it and they kept being like
stop talking the gods was gonna fall out
I was like damn that anesthesia just
kind of fire I'm thinking about getting
it hooked up like an anesthesia room at
home just to chill out to not my
experience when did you go into
anesthesia I did not yes that's why it
was not my experience when I got my
wisdom teeth taken out I just got the
the shot I didn't get put under and yeah
I was regretted the whole day yeah it
was pretty brutal crying like a baby it
sounds like it was it sounds like it was
one of the most traumatic experiences
the way you talk mine yes yeah because
they grinded it out of your mouth and
then you had to come back and do two
next day because you couldn't handle not
the next day I was like I was like oh
it's for a week but
um it was the worst experience of my
life bro really
there it is wisdom or painful than birth
what than giving birth
well what hurt more I forgot about that
one
it wasn't a bad experience though at
least that one has like a cute baby
right no of course there's a better
outcome at the end but yeah I just
wonder relative pain-wise
relative like trauma affecting on your
life kind of thing the the wisdom to
like really kind of like I carry it with
me really yeah wow yeah yeah no it I can
tell man but anyway here's AV uh after
the wisdom teeth got pulled
let's take a look
give me a little audio okay thank you
[Music]
[Music]
come to me
whatever
for money
that is not Justice
[Music]
I didn't that was pretty that was a lot
of dialogue here
[Music]
George Bush
yeah I didn't get that one
huh
poor guy
how long was he like that later
he fell asleep right when we got home
and then he was normal when he woke up
what if he got stuck like that forever
that's fun too yeah that'd be fun
was it cringing at this video that would
be
did you watch it later and remember that
he did that no he didn't he didn't
remember at all and also he was really
upset because he when they put him to
sleep they didn't even tell him that
they were gonna like right before they
did it he said he just went to the room
and then like he woke up and he's like
what the hell it's over already but like
he doesn't remember any of that that's
good though yeah that's so good and the
video too though I was trying to ask him
what he said in the beginning I wasn't
understanding and he didn't know exactly
either
by the way
shout out Teddy fresh real fast this
crew neck is going fast oh this one
already sold out Dan me and Dan are both
wearing it today bestie alert best
dealer we still have the um the Jade and
the Jade in my opinion is just gorgeous
absolutely beautiful have you ever seen
tie-dye like this in your life Dan have
you
uh no not really yeah yeah no it's
really you don't lie yeah it's a pretty
Primal tie-dye yeah absolutely yeah so
that's a really beautiful piece
this one's really nice too there's lots
of good stuff on the website right now
this is one I was wearing last week I
thought it was great
but yeah head on over to teddyfresh.com
also this women's polo shirt yeah I
don't know yeah that was pretty it's
pretty hard before
someone should wear this yeah someone
should wear this on the show next week I
can wear it next week all right love
that
anyway thank you thank you oh my man
that's who I've been missing how many
burgers you got in front of you Gabe
it's Friday baby today I'm the liver
King
[ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] the liver King you're the real
liver King what do you got there in
front of you
I got all types of burgers and meat I
got
the
Quarter Pounder and the Big Mac it seems
that you're more it seems you're more
the Burger King when you've got
McDonald's how interesting
Holly's burgers
have a bite if I could you got two
nuggies and like five french fries what
happened to the rest of the fries
I figured happened and uh you're going
shirtless today is that an homage to the
liver King
it's it's the almost to the Liberty baby
[ __ ]
yeah oh game is get
dude liver King is crying in shame right
now oh no you know Gabe some people say
that your abs are not real
some people say you have AB implants
Gabe your response to that
well
they're they're wrong you have to work
hard to believe it oh yeah wow look at
him go he's just stuffing those those
Burgers down I've never seen this kind
of
this kind of raw wow damn yeah damn gay
costume just radiating off of him right
now yeah do you feel your testosterone
levels going higher there Gabe
hopefully if I work hard at it yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah baby ow
good man
got any plans this weekend
the highest gotta do some more push-ups
yeah oh yeah yeah
make my abs real baby
if I paid for you to have AB implant
surgery would you do that for me
I don't I don't think so no no not even
for me huh
have you seen liver King's ABS bro you
could look like that I could I just
gotta I gotta just pump some muscles and
lose some more push-ups okay damn he's
earning I'm the Primal way yeah the real
way yeah yeah somebody defeating you
it's a mystery whoa that is Primal
dude Gabe just has servants on standby
wow burgers that is the life man is that
nickname that's gotta be Nick
yeah you know when we're going on
vacation by the way I'm down
I'm down 18 pounds 18 pounds what wow
thank you brother thank you I appreciate
it good job thanks man and but we're
going on vacation so I don't know how
crazy I'm gonna let it go because I want
to eat you know what I mean
right I believe the weekend
responsibly okay okay we gotta get that
18 pounds back
I I would believe you gotta gain 18
pounds back well that's not very nice
education
you think I'll get it all back in four
days
oh my god oh the Hedonism curious the
Hedonism well Gabe is Gabe is [ __ ] me
up because I want a burger now and uh
well Gabe I might gain it all back for
you buddy okay and we'll get it we'll
get AB implants together
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah it's Friday
baby
give me pink eye baby
good time [ __ ] baby [ __ ] me baby
pink eye of my dick [ __ ]
[Applause]
how about this one cut off my dick and
shove it up my own ass baby
shut up my ass
power nailed it hey how about this give
me more detail cut off my dick and shove
it up my ass so it gets lost and the
doctor has to take it out with tongs
baby
yeah it could be good maybe too too
wordy maybe huh yeah just a touch yeah
you have some ketchup on your face not
the I don't think yeah
all right Gabe well it's always it's
always a joy man I see you're primaling
out you you clearly got liver King's
message and that's all that matters you
know damn enough yeah baby
yeah all right thank you buddy always
pleasure I just got that all right yeah
thanks man you have a good weekend okay
[Applause]
pickle my dick in a jar [ __ ]
oh my God it's a murder scene
looking good dude did you get extra
ketchup on that yeah oh that's extra
ketchup that usually don't happen you
like ketchup on your on your Burgers
there lots of it yeah yeah a little
grape action the grape action is so
interesting that's some yeah all right
[Music]
oh
[Music]
that's very good
[Music]
uh Dandy was that girl I was seeing if
he was gonna hang up
bro you [ __ ] made me lose that table
and you coward
living a zoom call is sub Primal well
that's white claw game everybody what a
joy to hear from him on Friday
chaos folder 20 bucks thank you thank
you for the gifted uh since I was 15
I've been a huge fan my father wasn't
always around for me but Ethan your
videos always were there for me oh
boy you want to be my I mean [ __ ] I have
two sons but I think there's always this
place for
sure send your paperwork I'll get you
I'll adopt your ass [ __ ]
uh my name is Iden I sent a 70 Dono
yesterday for a b day shout out oh did
we miss that could I get a birthday I
sent it but yeah if we we were deep in
conversation
a happy birthday Aiden shout out Aiden
[Music]
all right moving on let's do a show so
um I guess first thing I want to talk
about yes is just debriefing from the
liver King situation that was yesterday
was a lot
obviously uh we also have probably maybe
my favorite story ever
dude have you heard about the lizard I
have not I have no idea holy [ __ ] what's
going on bro I was pulling my hair out
when I when I was going over this story
lizzo you know who that is pop start
yeah love her she's actually a
classically trained flute player I
didn't know that like she reached the
sheet music she's like a savant or does
this this is a font mean that she's like
also like you know it's really
challenged no no no no no no no no no
that's an autistic Savant right
I don't know if that's even the proper
terminology for it nowadays uh the
phrase that you're thinking of is idiot
savant which well that doesn't sound
very nice it's not
I don't I don't think anybody calls it
autistic though well isn't there well
what's the name first I think you're
thinking more like a prodigy oh here no
it's called Savant syndrome sure yeah
Savant syndrome is a rare condition in
which someone with significant mental
disabilities demonstrates certain
abilities far in axis of average yeah I
don't think she has any mental
disability though she's just no I know
she does I'm trying to get those she's
just got killer flute chops I'm just
trying to get the I didn't want to make
sure I wasn't saying something insulting
to her apologies though to everybody
else
I'm doing my best
a rain man syndrome you guys know what
I'm talking about I just wanted to make
I know she's on the rain man for crazy
right yes
Charlie Babbitt yeah well anyway she's
like this incredible flute player so she
went she got invited by the Library of
Congress to visit there they have a
whole museum on like
um
like historical flutes and she was doing
a concert there and they let her play
one of these flutes and the right wing
reaction to this is unlike anything I
mean it's so embarrassing for them how
is the fluid become political oh my God
this I can't wait to go over this but
one thing at a time you know the chess
cheating thing I've been trying to do
that yeah podcasts are cheating lots of
cheating going on but
yeah so liver King was a
was a hit yeah I watched the whole thing
I could not as soon as you guys showed
that board with all the gooey raw stuff
that was like
my nightmare yeah mine too honestly and
I know you don't even like
you you taught me because my mom would
always like handle raw chicken when she
cooks it and it's just kind of like not
be that careful about it and I know that
you're very like nothing can touch yeah
I mean cross-contamination is pretty
basic cooking uh protocol but your
family's next level like Elish family
they'll cook this big old meal on Friday
and they leave that [ __ ] out all day
yeah and then they put it in the fridge
I was like okay that's how we do it
around here but I'm talking like 10
hours out bro that's what a lot of uh I
don't know a lot of the Sephardic kind
of Jewish home-cooked food is you like
you make it and then you live it out the
whole day I never got sick eating it so
yeah or at least not that I know of I
mean I constantly have diarrhea so who
knows what's what's causing what you
know like them the Moroccan place that
we used to go eat yeah like that food
they had it on the heaters
yeah yeah but if you keep it warm it's
room temperature where it's the big
problem yeah
um oh my God they're people already
posting about your hair yeah the reason
I pulled up the subreddit is because
there were so many posts liver King post
yeah and I gotta say I didn't want to
you know make a hostile environment for
the liver King obviously we're not like
the most sympathetic crowd for him
but I thought it was interesting to see
him challenged in some regards because
I was kind of curious if you look at our
comment section it's it's fairly
critical of liver how are you going to
milk an oat I thought you did great
because like first of all he's a guest
yeah yeah exactly
um you want to be able to have all kinds
of guests you don't want to alienate
people by like you know
uh disagreeing with everything they
are gonna say there's only two combative
like it's not a debate no it's a
character you know and he's like he was
telling his crazy stories and
personally I wasn't buying like 90 of it
but I have a lot but it was really fun
it was a lot of fun I went back and
watched it and honestly
uh I had a I thought it was really a fun
episode I like doing it with Hassan as
well yeah kind of we both come from a
very different point of view I feel like
and that that's really good it was kind
of cute for me to see Hassan where
normally I would be I was like I can
relate to where myself you had a next to
you
did you have sympathy for him yeah yeah
but it was great I liked it
um this moment everybody loved I gotta
say this I wasn't sure how this was
gonna play because I I prepared this
really fun stupid silly game
and actually I thought it was going
really well the Primal not Primal I
would ask liver I'm just going to show
you a picture you told me to Prime them
yeah and we're having a lot of fun with
that and then he started getting I guess
he started getting scared because he saw
that I might be political
I think religious he was not down
yeah we go God Primal not Primal it's
like Primal just say primary and then
Jesus is when he and then I showed him
the planet Mars bro and that stumped him
he goes he goes I don't know anything
about Mars
wait I missed that one yeah but I don't
remember the planet Mars one well he
said NASA was Primal yeah yeah yeah
I think he had all kinds of
contradictions in general and his
approach to life but yeah I was get I
was getting to um I was getting to
vaccines you know Primal subprime that
would have been fun
that wasn't in there but I have a
feeling that's what he may have
suspected was coming yeah and why he was
like you know what he's anti-vaxx for
sure yeah our ancestors just died of
polio bro uh there was a lot of actually
interesting fact checking
which you know when you host someone
that's basically their whole identity is
misinformation Medical misinfo
I guess you have some due diligence to
try to give the scientific perspective
yeah that's true because you don't want
to like
I would say early on you were doing that
quite a bit but at a certain point it's
like like you said you don't want it to
be combative yeah and so it's just like
yeah literally the whole episode is just
gonna be you guys like arguing well and
also when he he's got this whole shtick
that he's got dialed in and he's got all
his factoids and stuff and all of his
statistics yeah there's no way that even
the smartest most melt well-read person
is going to be able to Parry or correct
everything it would take some research
you'd have to do some homework to be to
be prepared to answer everything yeah
when he's like this tribe in Africa and
then this try you know it's like okay
man the the man it fascinates me yeah I
am so obsessed with not like just from
like a scientific standpoint
specimen pretty studying him like a
caveman pretty much you know basically
uh uh what was that movie where they
found a caveman locked in snow oh oh
Encino Man yeah
like what blows me away is how he
acquired his wealth yeah that's it that
was the one point yeah that he didn't
answer I'm sorry no whatever he said was
like the biggest nonsense that he was
not honest in my opinion because he goes
okay well we bought a dentist practice
for five million dollars and I'm like
okay well clear you had a lot of money
but he says they're both High earners so
maybe they just got a mortgage okay I
can I can do that
but even to go from like working at a
dentist office
to owning a dentist uh office plus like
the whole crew and equipment and the
building like how do you do that in one
or two years because that's kind of wait
is that what they said it was only one
or two years I mean the timeline
because Danny was like also two years
later we already had a kid and already
sold everything well it I don't know and
he rolls in here with like a five-man
camera dude he's super rich I don't I
don't get like there's something missing
and he's got Lamborghinis and McLaren's
mind you that that could just be for
show but no it's not he's super rich
it's just definitely it's dumbfounding
to me I don't get it he's got that um
uh who's that other Jack dude who's just
Rich for no [ __ ] reason yeah he's got
that blizzarian like Rich Aura the part
that really had me raising my eyebrows
because I know about building a business
I know about marketing
he goes and yada yada yada I built a 100
million dollar company overnight and I
was like whoa whoa how do you get your
custom it doesn't work like that like
you got there's got to be a story of how
these people came to buy your
supplements and I'm sure they're the
best best quality products but like
that's just not how businesses work and
he goes they just came bro and I'm like
okay he said something that that I maybe
I'm contriving how he made his money he
might have come up with some medical
device patents like that him he's a
chemist like he's really add up though I
don't know I don't know what to believe
now he throws his curveballs every day
and then um
when he said I just made a website it's
like
no so he made it himself imagine him
saying that a chalk thing they would
kick him out like tomorrow oh for sure
but um you know
I think the the truth is probably
something far less interesting and
because his whole thing is like
self-made caveman [ __ ] I mean he it
could be something as simple as him or
his wife has a rich family and that's
not a story anybody wants to tell him
that was right if I if I had to if I was
a betting man inheriting land
I just I headed a ranch in Texas exactly
that all being said I mean the guy's the
real deal I mean he's definitely come he
is what he says
when he uh went to go shake my hand his
arm extended and within a millisecond
the smell oh yeah it still smells in
here I smelled it I caught a whiff when
I walked in you guys I so that doesn't
translate over the just watching I can't
I don't know
just imagine he exercises Non-Stop and
he just he doesn't use soap he doesn't
shower or brushes teeth or wipe his ass
22. you guys did better than I ever you
and Hassan because like it came up on
the show and you guys like talked about
it a little bit yeah they were
downplaying it significantly it was
intense it was intense I think like
three minutes she like pulls out her
candle she's like this please oh my God
he had a slightly candles yeah yeah I
had a pumpkin spice candle lit back here
but then like the smell with the candle
I think then it gets worse yeah and how
is the wife a dentist and they don't
brush their teeth that's my the other
thing it's like
I started thinking about that afterwards
his wife is this prolific dentist yeah
the man does not use toothpaste he
doesn't floss he doesn't brush his teeth
I mean it just sounds like she also like
whatever she's a [ __ ] doctor but he
was saying that they all live that so
she would also not break how do you
spend your whole life becoming a dentist
and be like I'm not brushing my teeth
ever again it just doesn't make sense
because you gotta chew on sticks primals
I think the guy brushes his teeth I'll
be honest his teeth look fine and I
think he just because he [ __ ] rushed
I I think if he ever comes back in here
again we need to do like a breath check
or something like oh [ __ ] no I'm not
putting my nose I'm getting close to
that man you know I'll leave that to you
though
I'll do it
but the man is so yaked
I think he's taken survey so I'm sorry
liver I just I'm sorry bro he said he
doesn't
the thing is like he was dishonest or or
or let's just say
not truthful about enough things where
it's like okay he's he's doing
everything is in question he's a
character
he's committed to this character this
isn't who he is at home right or at
least not to the extent that he's
thinking he takes steroids I will give
him he's he is without a doubt a showman
absolutely out of that no he's super
charismatic like you told him yeah he's
an Entertainer like that it was fun to
watch even though like the stuff he was
saying was complete cuckoo it was really
fun to watch it was super fun to bounce
things off of him but his people are
asking in the chat what did his teeth
look like in person they looked fine
like good normal good there was white
yeah they were white he didn't have any
like rotting you know sometimes when you
don't brush your teeth for years you
have like crazy plaque buildup
even because he says he even eats fruit
I mean fruit has sugar in it you're
gonna have to brush your teeth after
that
maybe if he was just eating meat you
could be like well maybe there's no
sugar in his diet so there's no plaque
or build up the man eats fruit
he gonna have to brush his teeth the man
eats rotting carcass it's I mean how do
you not brush your teeth after that you
know it's just right taste out of your
mouth he eats raw where did it when did
he eat well I'm I'm being I'm excited so
in general is he like against medicine
and just like yes anything developed he
was very careful to yeah to couch that
though like when you asked about the
prostate thing yeah he was like I don't
I personally don't believe I need
checkups like this but if you are if
you're not living the Primal lifestyle
you should see a doctor which is like
okay I appreciated that because you know
a lot of these charlatans would be like
no never but but he that was a good
responsible answer that I appreciated
yeah I think it is playing a pretty
smart game of otherwise he would just
get banned from everywhere right saying
stuff like that you know it's just like
it's technical dangerous misinformation
yeah that's that is interesting but yeah
no he was
he was uh right on in that regard
um but it seems that
it seems that the man is just not into
doctors or Dentistry or really of
anything as a woman
I cannot stand everything that he talks
about it's all like the top most toxic
manosphere values that I could imagine
and even also like
uh being pregnant we all I'm assuming
everybody at this point is watching the
new Game of Thrones show like you see
what they have to go through with
pregnancy without like medicine and
everything that's been developed like
why would I want to go back to primal
I I know I know why would I want to do
that to myself and like I mean his whole
theory of Primal is so inconsistent like
he chooses to be Primal and how he eats
but he but he's flying a private jet and
he wants an expensive watch yeah and
like well he he has ways of justifying
it but then when I go well what's the
difference between sharpening a stick
and editing our genes and he goes oh
well you're just you're one of those
guys huh and I'm like well you're that
guy more you have a billion exceptions
across the video he drinks beer too like
is that is that Prime
according to his diet he'll say yeah he
would say yeah and for raising kids like
the it's all about like oh you go to man
up
you gotta take a knife to your head I
hope Amazon kicks my ass that was uh
that was a wild ride because that was
the most interesting at one point he was
talking about how CPS came to his house
and
I was really like oh God that's horrible
that's scary but then like immediately
afterwards he was like yeah and so all
my friend all my kids friends come over
and I put machetes up to their head and
I pay them if they'll let me Splash
their head and make them bleed and I was
like okay CPS
[Music]
before he said it the the chat was all
talking about CPS see I was really I was
reading the chat yeah at all I wanted to
be in the moment yeah but uh and I don't
know I I I don't know man and then he
talked about how his kids were sick yeah
and the only thing that cured them was
liver yeah and I I questioned that uh
personally it seems probably to me and
again I don't know what actually
happened only he does right yeah is that
a lot of young kids
have allergies to certain things then
they go away as they grow you can grow
out of allergies a lot of times
especially kids grow out of allergies it
could also be that the they were
not that healthy because he was
switching them
to the liver and he mentioned epipens
and then not wanting to take epipens and
from what I understand if you need a
EpiPen you should carry it if you need
an EpiPen it's not like you just shove
raw liver in the mouth and then pray
that the shock subsides
yeah he says he starved them for three
days yeah I don't know the thing is the
kids seem happy I think I don't know and
and the thing is is how much of his
exactly here did you see that no not the
kids weren't just his wife okay right
right how much is real it's it's such a
character that I I don't know he might
just not have realized the audience that
he's speaking to would not think that's
badass you know what I mean I really
don't know how much of that was even
real
I would be super impressed and honestly
captivated if he was just at home a
normalized dude and he was like eating
broccoli and chicken and rice and she
had well Zach Zach who has been
following for a while he he mentioned
this morning that if you go back to like
his early videos you can tell like it's
before the characters really kicked in
and he's way like he's still about like
you know the naturalistic he looks like
lifestyle or whatever can we see yeah
his first video on his Instagram he's
like hi I'm Brian Johnson send me that
right now
I want to see it so I think over time
he's just really leaned into this
over-the-top character and so it makes
it hard to separate fact from fiction a
little bit
um here this was I don't know why this
was so funny to me I was watching this
last night because everyone's like oh
that [ __ ] was so awkward and to me I was
really just having fun with it and then
I guess she started getting nervous
I'm gonna hide the replay well also here
I'll always watching it I didn't seem
that awkward to me but yeah well here
here
landlocked tribes uh uh can you give me
some volume yeah it might be turned down
on your laptop like the actual uh
operating system volume let me see you
hit the
it's maxed really hitting us so low is
the pad on me yeah I'll cranked right
now Ethan so you should be all the peace
treaty to exchange at least one day out
of the week because Seafood was required
uh to express their health and happiness
so
um Seafood uh fish eggs and fish have
always been and listen we don't do a lot
of it but one day a week we do some
seafood okay so no I would say it's
absolutely Prime so having fun
everything's going good and how about
keeping cholesterol levels below 200
milligrams DL yeah I don't know if you
know but that's synonymous with lowering
your testosterone the prime we don't do
we don't do blood tests well we don't do
clubs I already did a blood test it's
online Google what about the planet Mars
that's like an easy one right in the
planet Mars I mean it's a Celestial body
but what he could he gets all stumped on
Mars watch this
[ __ ] I don't know anything about it okay
we refused to answer are you giving is
it giving Vibes like is it giving sub
problems
Tim's pretty good
pretty good it's a planet uh what about
Mars the the Roman God of War you get
real nervous what else is there about
him well tell me something about him I
don't know he's a mythological God of
War it's fine what about birth control
uh
birth control is probably not Primal
interesting you don't see condoms well
and say what you're thinking well and
then I was like well hold the [ __ ]
phone you make it sound like you and
your wife are just like [ __ ] all the
time where's all the kids at
of course not you know but again this is
such a topic agreed with that one
condoms but you guys must be using
contraceptives you only have two kids
and it sounds like you guys [ __ ] I guess
I missed this part this is something
that I'm gonna go back to what I said
earlier you know once we get to this
level listen
he's got this whole theory of Life we've
waiting for if contraceptions are not
subprimal
I'd like to know what what's his
solution there yeah is he does he just
pull out
I don't think that's effective enough if
this guy's as virial
as he says
I mean we don't we don't talk about that
we don't yeah fair enough very
respectful uh what about selling feet
picks online
you know I'm I'm not really enjoying
this anymore so I'm gonna be like hey
look okay we can call it off yeah yeah I
mean I get it if you like doing that I
was just like I I don't really enjoy
that and hey are you saying you say no
and we're out I appreciate that yeah
that's about it yeah but I I don't know
they got a little yeah got a little
heavy there
um there was one moment
when he got really angry at me hold on
I'll pull it up
he's people said they were scared for me
um
here here it is I don't know if you saw
this here's the thing
um yeah
um here's the thing
um never talk about my wife in this
context okay but yeah
here's the thing
I didn't I didn't really take it as a
serious yeah I don't know I thought your
reaction was perfect if he was trying to
be a serious threat I didn't perceive it
like
I do feel because that happened first
yeah and then when you're doing the game
when you brought up his sex life with
his wife again it was right after that
that he said he's out contraceptives you
said you got you guys [ __ ] like bunnies
right I didn't ask him to verify okay
well I'm just saying obviously you guys
use contraceptives because he was always
talking about how you become more your
libido goes crazy when you have
testosterone like me so I was like okay
this guy [ __ ] Non-Stop
I mean that's what he's putting out in
the world that's what he's saying yeah
um here's the thing
um never talk about my wife in this
context okay
you gotta remind me of Nathan Phil there
yeah okay
but you know what I've been doing this
long enough I'll be honest that I
actually I'm much better equipped the
handles yeah it's like this because uh
I've learned that once someone's
uncomfortable or awkward you just drop
it immediately and it's quickly away
from it right where before I had this
impulse to like stay there and Linger on
it and taste it and feel it
and that's that's not good for a show a
live show or the guest the guests hate
that and most of all I look like a
[ __ ] idiot when I do that
yeah so um
you're first on the subreddit you know
the whole time by the way are I saw a
comment saying it and I was also
thinking it like the whole time was just
thinking what Dan is thinking right now
it's just like everything was so
extreme from the misinformation to the
stuff he was saying to the interaction
of everybody
I'm looking for that one post that I was
just on if I go back
I wasn't here yesterday but oh you
weren't yeah no I missed it because I
was taking care of baby but I came in
today and I opened the fridge I don't
know if you guys saw this yet there's
like a huge jar of like how parts
that my friend is a penis
you don't want to say penis yeah they
left it for us they left us a parting
gift and actually I wanted to throw a
possibly to you guys if anybody wants to
uh rod and try the Pickled uh penis it
is cooked
so you're looking at me well I was like
this is a joker moment kind of a joker
brain move to eat eat the bull yeah
because that's our Joker brain yeah Zach
penis I don't care about that [ __ ]
anymore
oh [ __ ] that penis oh we found
the line we find after all these years
we found the line
eating pickled bold yeah you're out
Joker brain is is over
I was thinking though watching it is I
love my sub Primal husband dude and all
you sub Primal man out there I love you
thank you ELO yeah I was very nice I
can't relate because he did say that I'm
extremely Primal primals yeah I don't
know yeah yeah I mean they always go be
like so Primal it's like bro yeah I'm so
Primal I mean what the [ __ ] you want
from me I live in a house you know what
I mean I like the inner I leave my Wi-Fi
on you wipe your ass you know crazy [ __ ]
like that
oh AB is in our I fee I feed my children
actual food right yeah you see the snow
day bee just sent from home because he's
watching from home Venus is not Halal oh
is that right
I mean yeah just in general like
so there you go eat one it's just not
right right really there's a rule
against eating penis not specifically so
there's probably a mitzvah for it wait
so why do you say it's not Hello uh
what's your what's your evidence for
that
I mean it might just be in scripture
right well I'd like to see the quote is
bull penis hello I need a reference
let's find out
uh uh let's see
penis Ian you you're you're like the
Tank Man you usually [ __ ] with anything
would you it's the one that he thought
was uh the subprime one by the way yeah
because you guys you guys definitely did
some misdirection on him yeah it um he's
right it's it's not
the seven things that are parts of the
animal in uh Islam flowing blood penis
testicles vulva glands urinary bladder
and gallbladder I'll tell you what I
wish I was a Muslim yesterday man
those things out of my mouth well it's
probably not Kosher either yeah probably
not I should have pulled that card the
bowl testicles is probably the worst
thing I ever taste and I swear to you
that taste was in my mouth all [ __ ]
night I could not get rid of it can you
describe it like what it was like a it
was like a really metally sour
like uh really kind of just yeah sour
metally ill and it just sits real real
it just kind of is a real low profile
flavor but it just sits on your sits on
you man gross so [ __ ] foul dude I
actually had a dream last night I swear
to God that there was a massive
parasitic worm oh no that was rolling
out of one of those meats like a big red
parasitic worms and I was like oh my god
dude oh my God I just put that in my
mouth
oh yeah and he thought we should all
have a worm in our tapeworms yeah yeah I
think the uh the thumbnail it hits you
pretty pretty hard right yeah the worst
pain of your life I believe yeah so
obviously the thumbnail is Click bait
that's the uh
that the Bell testicles was stuck in my
mouth and that's basically all there is
to that so thank you guys for tuning in
worst pain in my life
so uh by the way we uh should do our ad
read so before that uh Ian will you try
the bowl penis I mean I did I chewed
that [ __ ] up for like a minute
then spit it out [ __ ] horrid but you
crushed that and you could tell me if
which is worse that or the Tsum strowman
and I think the balls were worse but we
don't have those anymore I'm not
touching this one uh no one else is
gonna do it nobody I'm not gonna eat it
I'm not gonna eat the bone or pro bono
so put a put a price on it
[Music]
I'll give you a hundred bucks I don't
know you guys have been driving for this
[ __ ]
let me think about it hundred bones 100
bones that's a lot of money how much to
eat the whole [ __ ]
oh all of a sudden money got involved
and Zach's back in the whole [ __ ] you're
not gonna I'll give you a thousand
dollars to eat that whole [ __ ] there's
no shot
it's not gonna happen dude it's huge
I could I could even do it higher and I
feel bad because because you're just not
gonna get it but it's massive and
there's I'll give you five thousand
dollars if you eat that whole car
oh
spicy five thousand dollars
really thinking about it telling you
there's no way why I agree with you then
hit Zach's lips he's gonna freak out no
shot it's huge it's so big and it's so
gnarly it's super hard to eat five
thousand bucks it ain't worth it yeah
now for Ian on the other hand 50 bucks
for him oh [ __ ] he's gonna get it watch
out what are you doing now because
well bring it out here put it bring it
out we'll just put it watch out for Lina
that's all I'm saying well she can until
it's uh oh I thought maybe said it's
okay wait he did but it's not oh it's
not
yeah so here it is oh they look like
brought first but it's actually just a
pickled [ __ ] no
hi I'm dick tip
and wasn't it like plopping yesterday
like it was making noise
up and down and I was like dude do not
[ __ ] leave this here I was really
telling them like don't leave that here
take that [ __ ] with you what does the
chef do if everything is raw
yeah that shows because we're kind of
getting I guess he Seasons the food when
they're at home so it is yeah he he has
a
I mean it was still prepared it was like
cut up and stuff and cut up
the circumcision yeah like the the
culinary school the bone marrow and
everything and yeah I mean it had to be
like sliced and prepared for serving
I've seen in other videos you can't do
that he cooks food and makes like sushi
too okay
yeah so I don't know who Ian is there
shot here uh is it like the same um
portion you had yesterday just like uh
no you got to take more of a medallion
not much bigger not much bigger but a
full cross section you know what I mean
for what what do I get 100 bucks dude
let me see the portion I probably dude
it also goes and show history that's
true beyond the money I still hype you
up for that Zoom Stroman to this day bro
liver King said that I'm like the sub I
know it you know it got to me a little
bit uh oh I see yeah he's dead wrong man
he is dead wrong there's only one way to
overcome that if I gotta eat a dick why
don't you do it and then we'll send him
the video
oh by the way I wanted to see this video
Zach sent me of the first Instagram
video
shirt yeah he's wearing a shirt first of
all
my mission is to put back in what the
modern world left out if you want to
follow along and learn more follow me
here
I'm Brian Johnson my family and tribe
call me liver King my mission what the
modern world left out if you want to
follow along and learn more follow me
here like he's not he isn't like
necessarily adapted though yeah no it's
definitely a different Persona nobody
cares about Brian Wilson so this is
probably a year ago I care about Brian
Wells
was that only a year ago yeah he blew up
fast man this was from August 22 2021
yeah about a year ago
pretty incredible
how many followers does he have he's
popular I mean on Instagram he's got
like two million but on I think tick
tock's his biggest wow
all right let me thank our sponsors you
guys think if you want to eat a dick
Medallion
um
can we
remove the jar from the table
um for the hellofresh battery that we're
about to do portion and if you can do me
no no I was about to say if you could do
me a favor and not reference that yeah
please someone take the jar you think
yeah okay I'm gonna come remove it you
got it thank you Lena
yeah let's just kind of
take a beat here
yeah before we do hello fresh let's get
that penis out of here please thank you
that's good let's get the vibe going on
some good vibes
now that you're hungry
let me tell you about our favorite
in the world it's hellofresh folks we
love them you know them all fupa
Troopers love hellofresh and by the way
they're running a new deal that's insane
oh my God yeah take a look at this food
while I tell you this if you go to
hellofresh.com after dark 65 and use the
code after dark 65 you get 65 off what
yeah I know plus free shipping
that's pretty good yeah what is
hellofresh they send you pre-portioned
farm fresh ingredients
straight to your door they send them in
this great little shipping container
with
dry ice or ice packs that keeps it fresh
all day nice and cool on your doorstep
and what they have here is the perfectly
measured balanced delicious meals you
see here
they send you an info card about all the
ingredients about the meal and exactly
how to cook it
it's actually cheaper than eating out
you know and also it's even cheaper than
going to the grocery store because they
send you the exact amount of ingredients
you need you don't end up wasting a
bunch of products and stuff it's super
super good
it's healthy it's whole you're gonna
absolutely love hella fresh like all
Super Troopers are this is all picks
from the fupa Troopers by the way that's
right I cannot believe it oh [ __ ] what's
that one that one I can't believe
who would send that picture
damn
okay I mean look at those grill marks
wow wow wow wow baby talk to me so
symmetrical uh hellofresh is here to
make your hectic fall week nights a
little easier and a lot more delicious
they're stressed out take the stress out
of meal time and save time no fuss
recipes are ready in a snap also
have a packed schedule for this fall
hellofresh has meals covered with a
weekly selection of 30 plus recipes and
70 plus convenience items all delivered
to your door
yeah so like I said here guys go to
hellofresh.com after dark 65 and use the
code after dark 65 for 65 off plus free
shipping thank you thank you to the
hellofresh America's number one meal kit
all right yeah I love it okay
okay let's go thank you Sandy Martinez
for the gifted 10 gifted yo you members
who are gifting Subs I mean this is
what an altruistic beautiful act you can
do because now there's that Tuesday
podcast right and now they're they're
part of this exclusive Club
that uh gets to hear me whisper in their
ear for an hour a week
um you know people said about that that
they didn't realize like how soothing
your voice is yeah so they'll sell a lot
of comments like that it kind of
reminded me of when we used to talk on
Skype a long time ago when we went to my
voice
it's tell me more interesting I didn't
read that about you very interesting
very nice voice
I don't know maybe it's the mic there
but I felt like my voice sounded better
on that mic I think it's just that only
listening and no video
yeah
concentrate I'll do a boyfriend
for Tuesday
hey baby how was your dad let me pick up
those bags for you they look heavy what
is this um sent this
so they're not knockoff he says new pick
that's all I said
what's inside though I still don't know
it could be who is it foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
coward
so I'm still want to talk about liver
King I'm sorry guys maybe you guys are
over it but I just like this topic is
endlessly interesting I know
I feel like I had so many thoughts when
I was listening I can't I don't even
know like I can't even remember
everything now yeah
um so a lot of the oh one thing I wanted
to say you know if you go to the
comments section
they're fairly contentious and which I
get you know I don't think he's ever
been on a podcast with fans like ours
because our fans are I think pretty
smart certainly not manosphere people I
think the man the podcast space is like
almost dominated entirely by manosphere
stuff yeah and his root is like Bro
Science yeah because I when I saw the
comments on ours
I was like I wonder if he's getting
roasted everywhere because he's kind of
a goofball and I went over to like
impulsive
and the comments there like this guy is
a [ __ ] hero to me he's so right about
everything and I was like thank God
those aren't our fans man it's like
those comments on the Jordan Peterson
um
oh yeah shattering
shatteringly insightful
yeah so I was like you know what
our fans are awesome they're pretty
smart and like I don't know pretty
pretty they're smart they're talented
they're funny
they're good Cooks
true and hot
so hot the best people
they're all wealthy successful yeah
um spontaneous oh yeah the part where
liver says I don't know what he's I says
well are your kids liver princes he says
I don't even know what that is and he
said well it's the son of a king
I think he thought I was trying to
insult him but I was real literally like
well if you're a king that makes some
Prince by default how are you gonna milk
an oat that's a bad question you just
soak oats in water and then that's the
oat milk right
how are you gonna milk an oat right
I mean that's how oat milk is made I
don't think it's that mysterious I don't
know anything that's just what I assume
I mean how many other ways is there to
make oat milk and Dan maybe you can fact
check me on that yeah I gotta say I've
uh
milk research listen you take the oats
you put it in the water then you take
the oats out the oat milk
uh you mostly got it based off of what
I'm reading thank you man commercial oat
milk
God
commercial oat milk is made by combining
oats with water before Milling the
mixture into a fine consistency so wow
you missed the Milling but how do you
milk and oat there there you go it's
exploding Milk porn yeah we'll get to
that
um
I can't decide
um
yeah I guess they're not that mean
actually anymore
maybe it was more on Reddit
and then what you're talking about the
comments on YouTube YouTube's algorithm
on the comments section has
um well depending on how you look at it
either improved or worsened over the
years glad liver King is getting his
message out this video definitely made
me want to go vegan that's so true man I
love that guys that's so true and that's
why we love her uh
yeah have you noticed this Ethan I feel
like the YouTube comment algorithm like
which ones it chooses to put near the
top it like
it knows to not put the more hostile
ones there yeah yesterday when I was
looking through the comments he was
getting eviscerated it's always it's
always like the next day like I feel
like it evolves like usually right after
the show you'll see more negative ones
but then over time it kind of pushes the
more like just neutral to positive one I
think that's good I think that's cool
you know because the comment section is
usually accessible just watching my
algorithms get crushed like on Twitter
uh I always felt like it was showing me
the worst comments oh I complete Twitter
is 100 the opposite of what I'm
describing if 100 is a reality that it
puts the most hostile [ __ ] at the top
Twitter is a raffle yeah he's right he's
right about that by the way we have a
new Peterson crying clip too we do yeah
we do oh my God he was crying for in
cells man literally it's pretty good
yeah but honestly it was a really fun
fun episode
this guy is absolutely insane holy [ __ ]
this is hard to watch but so
entertaining yeah yeah he's damaging the
[ __ ] out of those kids too yeah yeah
yeah yeah that that has to be true
and the whole when I found out that like
he didn't have a dad
and um
I feel like there's a lot of just trauma
look
the man is obviously trying to prove to
himself that he
he was missing a masculine figure in his
life clearly
and is obviously over compensating
to levels we maybe have never seen
before
but we love that for him don't we folks
so let me read this because
um like I said it's a little bit of a
disservice not to correct some of the
misinfo he said
organ Meats eating organ meat is a good
source of nutrients and vitamins
argument is flush with saturated fats
and cholesterol and can actually be bad
for people who are at risk for heart
disease and as Hassan point out can
cause gout from increased uric acid the
rule of thumb is to make a organ meat
10 percent or less of daily calories
well what about a hundred percent
my dad I ate a lot of meat and a lot of
like Primal stuff yeah and he had gout
oh you're dead really bad yeah that's
that's yeah you did that's what it's
from and lots of problems yeah I think
liver King is gonna I think his tit
heart is probably gonna explode anyway
and you know I I hope not I don't want
him to die I want him to live forever
but I'm just saying
there's like a soul there's like a a
billion bovine Souls clamoring
from his heart
that is true a hexerhein detox reaction
this is about his kids having like
extreme
allergies this is absolutely horseshit
no Medical Institution recognizes as
being real it's a fictionalized detox of
toxins and micro microbes
they commandeer uh the Jairus
harshikheim reaction which are a rare
phenomenon that occurs after treatment
with antibiotics for people who have a
documented infection
there's a lot of stuff I don't know what
means here sphericotis yeah a lot of a
lot of big words in here all kinds of
stuff here's the question how many
Instagram followers does this person
have right what's your body fat [ __ ]
yeah
you got a six-pack
when he said his kids were experiencing
this it was likely him forcing his young
kids into ketosis due to a lack of
carbohydrates this is very dangerous for
children because the body will turn on
itself for fuel your brain is designed
to burn carbs specifically only cut them
out of your diet at the advice of a
doctor well he doesn't believe in
doctors subprime a loser
yeah this person sends some Primal as
[ __ ] I'm not gonna dick size sperm count
and testosterone can't believe I have to
say this but no eating a penis does not
make yours bigger oh man
Zach's out yeah hands out too [ __ ] the
best way to support male and female
fertility is to have a healthy diet and
is reduced in fats oh wait as they
affect the structure of spermatosos
other factors are poor vitamins and
fiber intake eating a balanced meal is
always better than a pack of crackers or
a hunk of Raw Liver what he said about
decrease in testosterone is correct only
if your reference sperm counts which
coincidentally is positively correlated
to the occurrence of obesity uh Kim sent
you the picture of how oat milk is being
made over here okay so so oh see that's
exactly what I imagined yeah you milk
you're literally milking the oh it comes
out
by the way that line reminded me of uh
you remember that movie Meet the [ __ ]
have nipples Greg can you milk me
how do you milk an oat such a good sound
bite
raw meat of any variety can be extremely
hazardous during the killing and cutting
process there are countless forms of
bacteria that accumulate and eat the
nutrients you can die from Catching
diseases found in raw meat there are a
few exceptions carefully prepared meat
from specific Farms some species of fish
are safe to eat raw
and even more can be flash frozen or
deep Frozen and becomes safe do not
attempt this yourself in his defense it
seems like they had done a
deep freeze
uh to kill the bacteria yeah no
they're doing it right I mean otherwise
they do would be sick all the time like
it's also like super rich so he he can
do things the right way
to like people who are not gonna be
super rich you know a chef with them and
so well that's fairies not quiet because
he offers an alternative which is his
pills yes Ah that's the secret you know
I was going to take his pills so he gave
me all the supplements and I was excited
to try it he's like yo you're gonna get
a bunch of energy okay I'll [ __ ] try
it so you're supposed to take it was it
three or twice six capsules yeah but how
many times a day it doesn't matter oh
yeah so you have to one serving is six
capsules and there was three bottles so
I would have to be taking 18 pills a day
and I said liver I ain't got time for
that you can you can spread it out
throughout the day
have you been doing it Kim I just did it
yesterday and today
I'm trying to cat liver out yeah
show how big it is yeah you need to eat
18 of these in a day man it sounds like
the Metamucil pills yeah totally and
these might even be bigger
and more disgusting because they smell
like oh yeah that's me maybe even bigger
yeah no no show me what 18 looked like
yeah he posted a clip uh thing today of
him Downing 30 in one serving and I
already take like vitamins he did I want
to see that yeah
that is impressive man I was thinking to
myself Ethan better not get sick from
this I was scared I'm not worried I was
super scared about catching a parasite
or something
I didn't actually swallow anything but
the bone marrow mm-hmm
I tried my best to swallow that penis
bro I tried so hard they were all
rooting for me I watched it back and I
was cringing because they kept rooting
for me for so long and I just I couldn't
get it down
us yeah so that's 18 right there so
there it is yeah
uh seed oils this is a weird Bro Science
thing I've been noticing where they're
saying like seed oils is like the most
unhealthy thing in the world it's very
odd pseudos can lead to cell necrosis
with leads to an inflammation which
leads to chronic disease this statement
is so blatantly false numerous clinical
and observational Studies have found an
inverse is true seed oil or any
vegetable oils were found to actually
often decrease inflammation of the
tissue chronic inflammation can damage
our body and cause cell necrosis so as
long as you are following the usda's
dietary guideline of reducing saturated
fats you are actually better off using
seed vegetable oil
that's a really big misinfo I see going
around today I don't know I don't know
what's with all this Bro Science they
like somehow find things that
and they use some like words that you
don't know so it seems like they've done
the research and it sounds like what
they're saying is fact and then it's all
made up like I don't know how this
phenomena it seems started but based on
my following Dr IDs and he's like my
best bud now it seems that a lot of it
comes from misinterpreting or
deliberately misinterpreting
yeah yeah so they could be like yo check
out this paper yeah but it's like or
maybe not even misinterpreting it but it
just being one paper
that you focus on but then there's like
10 others that disagree with it because
that's how science works it's it's the
amalgamation of all of it that you have
to look at and yeah but usually they
can't cherry pick but usually they don't
even have one but it's like yeah you
need to be equipped to know how to read
those research documents I feel like
yeah yeah like I don't know like was
this a small sample size and then is
there another one that's contradicting
it right I don't know
yeah that was kind of Dr Ed's point is
that
you shouldn't be drawing conclusions if
you don't know how to interpret the data
yeah I've learned that from your brother
oh thank you he's very good he knows a
lot of stuff and so I always ask him
World Records today nobody in the
history of capsule swallowing has ever
had 30 capsules uh probably probably
copyrighted
he's breaking a cap store world record
here guys
that's her new stop which is that Gala
all right go for it liver
no water
oh no he hits the water okay that's sub
Primal dude
I'm impressed you know that's
I guess as far as skills go oh sure I
mean I don't know how that's gonna help
him in the jungle but cam take 30 of
those now I'm good the only so far the
only uh side effects of experience is
just weird tasting burps oh yeah yeah oh
that's the liver oh and you know it's so
vile the blood they started passing out
blood and I'm like guys you said the
blood wasn't that bad it was bad and
there was a strong
yeah there was chunks of rose to the top
and I'm like guys there's better ways to
get iron no
yes yeah you don't have to travel away
on you savage
uh and then he keeps talking about the
massari tribe somebody pointed out these
this is a tribe I guess in Africa that
eats only milk meat blood and actually
interestingly he did not mention that
they have the lowest life expectancy of
all of the tribes this was the part that
really broke me when I saw that yeah 45
years is their average life expectancy
you don't say I mean [ __ ] when's the
last time in human history we we had a
45-year life expectancy it did
oh plague I don't know yeah probably the
Middle Ages it would be my guess another
huge point of Miss info that select
causes estrogen at the point that he
brought that up I was like I wasn't even
ready to push back on this because but
yeah that's that's a huge
that's a huge huge huge misinfo
consuming swipe products has no effect
on hormones whatsoever in males females
it actually has a stabilizing effect
feel free to enjoy your soy latte this
is a misunderstanding of a compound
found in many vegetables known as
isoflavos flavones
sunscreen I mean do I even need to say
sunscreen is one of the best inventions
that we've like straight up like
one of the best inventions ever has does
anybody hear anything further about they
they were it had it is good for your
skin obviously but there was like the
whole theory that it's what's killing
all the coral reefs is like all the
people swimming yeah I did read
something about this was like a few
years ago but I don't I don't know if
that's been since debunked or whatever
but how could it I just I have a hard
time believing it only because how can
there be a measurable amount of
sunscreen in the vastness of the ocean
it just seems kind of ins like possible
I've seen the effects of it firsthand
like in Israel people
just kind of like
get tan you know every summer it's
because just because you look cool when
you're 10. yeah so as a kid you know I
would do it and my mom as a kid did it
and a lot of people so you kind of get
to see how people
um age
and it's so bad for your skin well like
it's just awful this is actually one of
the most interesting this was I think
she was like a truck driver or he is a
guy actually
uh daily sun exposure on this side oh
from the window and then none on this
side and it's like there it is man
wow that [ __ ] works
you know unfortunately no it's so crazy
I just still like put oil on myself and
go lay in the sun yeah
and now I'm like how did I ever do that
I used to do the two you know kids you
feel like you're Invincible when you're
a kid yeah now I won't I like avoid this
if I'm in the Sun for a second I'm like
lubing all the way up we used to go
every weekend to the beach I never put a
sunscreen on I used to tell you I was
like you better put on some sunscreen
girl
though
yeah you have fairly olive skin
but it's still not good for no you know
I would say that for me I say the only
people that don't need sunscreen is
probably people's really really dark
skin I think they're fine
but I don't know that for sure yeah
always wear sunscreen with possible
radiation for every consumer object you
own is less than two percent of your
daily intake the effects of the
atmosphere and Sun are three times as
high if you want to avoid extra
radiation from objects stay away from
antiques
building materials and smoking any plant
antiques I don't I guess some antiques
have like radioactive things it seems
like a big statement
I've seen like yeah certain antiques I
know what that means
the Sun and space emit UV radiation
damaging ourselves in DNA it's a huge
cause for cancer sunscreen reduces UV
radiation um that's not true about dark
skin they're saying in the chat oh
really oh okay certain radioactive
materials were used in antiques because
of their unique color huh
yeah yeah it's kind of insane they used
to use like Radioactive
uh materials yeah I guess they didn't
know anything oh like radium and stuff
oh interesting watches in like the 50s
and 60s right yeah they're mostly
showing watches in this example
avoid antique stores if you want to live
whoa uh fascinating so yeah sunscreen
reduces the incident of various cancers
anywhere between 59 and 95 so wow that's
a good one and not only that you've seen
it makes your skin [ __ ] up bad yeah
when you see old people with beautiful
skin I have a feeling it's like it has a
lot to do with they wore sunscreen and
avoided direct sun I think
I'm gonna be true because I feel
I feel people don't age that well where
I come from it could be the sun honestly
it really could be yeah that's
interesting
hmm
yeah I'm a big fan of sunscreen you know
I've started driving in my car
and my hands are just in the Sun and
it's like really intense sun on my wrist
and hands and I notice my skin was just
getting so [ __ ] up and wild it was
like aging too fast my my wrists where
it bends so I started putting um
moisturizing sunscreen every day when I
drive to work it's already looking
better so
this is another one that I I just had
this is one of my pet peeves I [ __ ]
hate this guy he's so stupid it's just
so dumb this claimed that cell phones
Wi-Fi
cables are causing cancer it's just one
of the oldest and dumbest uh Miss infos
out there he kept saying don't don't
ever put a cell phone near your dick and
balls yeah yeah it's totally fine it has
nothing to do with fertility I remember
that was like a panic in like the late
90s like when I was a kid and I I
thought we've we've disproven that we
had a long time ago my mom still goes on
about that [ __ ] right like don't put
your phone in your pocket and don't put
a laptop on your lap
and tell Ethan she's like Tally's and
not put a laptop on his lap well yeah so
I mean that's good advice because the
when you put a laptop in your lap for a
prolonged period it can get really hot
but it's same for your it's like bad for
your balls in the same way going in a
hot tub is you know what I mean you're
gonna cause more infertility problems
just going in a hot tub or taking a hot
bath or something
it's just heat it's just the heat
exactly like some kind of radiation but
he was saying that phones and Wi-Fi and
radio frequencies put out ionizing
radiation which was 100 uh incorrect
it's non-ionizing and as I explained to
him
ionizing radiation is like what comes
from the Sun in outer space that can uh
destroy and damage our DNA which is what
causes cancer
you can avoid it and by the way it's
always pretty it's everywhere all at
once there's no way to [ __ ] like he's
like yo I'm putting my phone and and uh
airplane yeah it's like that's cool but
as you sleep there in your wooden plank
you're being bombarded from space with
ionizing particles all the time
also from the sun which you don't care
about sunscreen you can't avoid it as
everyone around you has devices
constantly emitting huge radio waves
that's another thing it's like do you
know how many radio waves and Wi-Fi
signals are constantly enveloping us
since the incident of phone cancer rates
have been stable right the phone has
been long enough now if it was causing
cancer we would have for sure yeah it's
been around for decades yeah however the
studies are mixed and systematic uh
reviews are still in progress keeping
phone near your balls is fine so long as
like Ethan said it's not hot you cause
more damage with baths that are too hot
and absolutely avoid hot tubs of
fertilities and imminent concern do not
feel your children in hot tubs
yeah asthma don't don't ditch the EpiPen
obviously
yeah he also did this one here where I
was classic I forget what was the
context but he's like yo we need to
worry about what's in front of us before
it was something
when I think you were talking about GMO
people he's like I don't give a [ __ ]
about them we need to get our own lives
in order basically
that's another pet peeve of mine is
people demonizing GMOs which is like the
greatest breakthrough in human
technology maybe ever I mean one of the
great breakthroughs obviously GMO can be
used uh for evil like pretty much any
technology
you know
uh but but the science itself is not
inherently evil it's very very very very
very very good
so we love GMO
I stand GMOs
I say more GMOs when Hassan talked about
the seasonality of fruits and turkey
that reminded me like it's the same in
Israel and is that because of GMOs
because in Israel it's so like oh you
only get strawberries in those two
months and then there's just no
strawberries or avocados like here we
have avocados all year and mangoes and
you know well you know in California is
special because we have this super
fertile Valley which is called but then
a lot of times when something goes out
of season here we can get it from Mexico
which is lower tropical or South America
which is in a
so I don't know but he's probably I he's
got to be right I mean I think he's
right that's yeah GMO all day every day
baby let's [ __ ] go right now I love
it I love that I can eat avocado all
year round yeah and like a sunset if the
tomatoes don't taste good do you grow
your own or go to a [ __ ] Farmers
Market that's fine you know what I mean
so there it is
um
so much liver King stuff though
there's just so much to unpack I know my
head was spinning at one point I got
overwhelmed I was like oh I have so many
questions
Jasmine uh Happy 28th birthday
queen queen queen queen Queen
We love a queen
this is from September 11th okay well
what was the context of this one
oh I was just showing what a chef did oh
he seasoned the food for him yeah and
there's like a bunch of sushi prepared
works on Saturday I'm liver King Chef
Lionel and here's what we made for
dinner tonight we're gonna start off
with some monkfish Sashimi head this is
going to be called Poor Man's Lobster
because how much it tastes like lobster
we have some testicle hand rolls we got
some raw liver Sushi we have a liver
king size sashayana right here yeah bro
what and God's [ __ ] name was that
wait what was that Sushi we have a liver
king size Sashimi right here I guess
it's just that shame it why is it it
looks so big and how does he eat that I
really want to know
that has some bluefin tuna sushi we got
some salmon sushi we have the carcass of
the bluefin tuna right there you can't
get any fresher than that we got our
Burger bro do you know how much that
cost honestly this is really making me
just want to be a vegan
yo do you know how much a giant bluefin
tuna costs like that in its entirety
isn't that like
fifty thousand dollars or something
man that could be I have no idea
I've seen in in fish markets in Japan
when they catch these big uh valuable
Sushi fish they auction them off to
dealers I think that might be a cert
they call it Toro I think it might be a
certain type that is caught there I
don't know if every bluefin tuna is
super expensive oh okay maybe maybe yeah
it could be
we're gonna have some bluefin tuna sushi
we got some salmon sushi we have the
carcass of the bluefin tuna right there
you can't get any fresher than that we
got our burgers with cheese we have our
bone marrow fluffy mashed potatoes and
to top everything off we have some slow
braised ribs that's what we're having
for dinner tonight liver King Chef
Lionel out he forgot to mention they're
having flies too yeah
I would be a lot more comfortable if
that raw fish was on ice or something
you know
he says it doesn't get more fresh than
that I mean I beg to differ
just saying
I guess they do catch Bluefin in Texas
this is where he lives but Dallas isn't
on the water so I'm just saying it does
get fresher not the split hairs
but I'm gonna split hairs
local Blowfish a bluefin tuna wholesale
prices per pound cost between 20 and 40
uh while you can be paying a maximum of
200 yeah okay 200 a pound for bluefin
tuna from Japan
so okay let's do the fly's costs though
are those free those are probably bonus
he doesn't need uh green so it's just
the garnish
it goes with it
um there was uh I guess that's about it
I'm just seeing if there's any other
pose
um
there was one other one I wanted to show
you guys
but uh
uh
dead air what was it I'm trying to look
on the subreddit for
there that air is so Primal dude dead
[ __ ] air right now bro
I gotta say there wasn't any dead air
yesterday because the liver King was so
energized from the moment he walked in
there was an electricity in the air it
was all it was quiet until he arrived
and then the whole room lit up again
he's he's got a certain Charisma yep
um by the way this comment the
personality this comment was amazing uh
he said he's physically tough
but let's see if he's mentally tough
let's see him eat five grams of shrooms
in total darkness
[Laughter]
I agree man
I'm out the other end vegan
I guess that's a revelation yeah that's
about it so there it is liver King
uh man
there's a lot to impact but you know
what
interesting guy very interesting guy
glad glad we had him on you know I don't
know who's he helping I don't know he's
getting very rich
I guess maybe he's himself in his family
maybe not hurting anyone
maybe he's hurting a lot of animals the
animals are dying for sure lots of
animals die for him
animals die
oh here's another post yeah this one is
what I saw this was a [ __ ] funniest
[ __ ] bro this is liver King unjacked
what the hell pork boy it does look like
pork boy in it it's not funny dude I
love that photo of Brian
it's got that white claw gay body right
there
well he's fine you know he's healthy
looks good Brian
so there it is liver King
not necessarily hurting anyone that's
what we're saying uh or is he I don't
know as long as our audience is educated
enough to question all those crazy
statements I think um yeah I think we
can just get entertained I was I was
telling the guys after the show yo [ __ ]
I don't think he sold one [ __ ] bottle
of that [ __ ] on our show not one maybe
I'm wrong though
maybe I don't know a lot of people watch
it may have caught a few I think he's
getting sales on Bradley Martin's
podcast and you know for sure uh here is
moving on now
somebody had this really funny post
because we were talking about soy face
yeah with liver I was cracking up Ethan
tries not to show a guest the pro lab
uh that's a good
Ethan tries to not have Jimmy Lee on the
podcast
where's your camel AB says Ethan tries
not to insult a guest before they come
on the show
impossible difficulty yeah yeah and uh
Ethan tries to pronounce
kleinwater Revival
uh Ethan tries to remember who Sam is
yeah that was funny give me a chuckle so
shout out to uh Mitch H3
[Applause]
there it is
um okay we have a challenge for you ELO
all right yes so we were talking about
Adam Levine okay when you weren't on
with us then and we were saying he's got
really bad tattoos so we were wondering
if you can tell us God who's ours worse
Adams or
uh oh Ben Affleck's oh geez take a deep
look
and I guess the the criticism is that
they're just kind of slapped on there
like default clip art it totally looks
like clay Park just California like
California it's like what what
why did you unmatch me yeah I absolutely
hate it can we see the back yeah the
back is is pretty masterful as well oh
my God and as cam pointed out what is
this it's like it's just a mermaid which
is super awesome composition like
cheese
also what do you think about the Supreme
underwear
it's like
it could do better that's what I think
too it's like you're Adam Levine you
don't have to wear some cream you don't
have to like do a hype flip yeah
okay so that's Adam oh my God you know
that that's crazy because I kind of feel
more repulsed right now by this than by
Ben Affleck whoa whoa give it to me I
don't know why okay well let me refresh
your memory because yeah because I I
know Ben Affleck was like the number one
worst tattoo yeah so before if some of
you are new to the show
oh that's tough I don't know some of you
who are new to the show we used to
debate we used to have a segment where
we would go over the worst tattoos and
over all of them we went through Ben
Affleck was consistently the worst that
was ELO's ruling she was thinking by and
so every time we find someone that we
think can rival him uh we throw it to
her so you have Ben Affleck's uh Phoenix
tattoo
makes me wonder how deep it goes with
our new audience can we do a poll I'm so
curious what they oh that's a good
that's a good because sure we used to
talk about this like years ago at this
point
just between the two Adam Levine yeah
who has the worst tattoos now do you
want to unpack this one a little bit why
you hate it so much
um it's awful
uh like personally I find it very ugly
I also just like I don't know you're a
Ben Affleck and then and
see that's why I think that Adam's
interesting because you always emphasize
that it's the fact that it's somebody as
famous as Ben Affleck has such a bad
tattoo yeah I'm Levine is kind of on the
same level yeah yes yeah that's why it's
a very hard no and I look at this I
always think well don't aren't you
impressed technically with the colors
and stuff like it's really good I don't
care about technique I mean you want me
to show you like amazing tattoos people
can do amazing stuff yeah it's true
yeah yeah very true I think that like
this just makes Ben Affleck Undateable
for me like I would not what about this
and this maybe I don't think he's
Undateable this I think is still
dateable yeah I would really urge him to
remove the California though that one's
the worst and that's divorce like we
can't you can't walk around like that
I think that Ben Affleck might still be
staying at the top
wow so you're thinking who's more
Undateable like if you saw that Ben
Affleck tattoo yeah and you were like
you're you're having the best time with
this guy you've been date you've gone on
a couple days I mean it's like
something's wrong with this guy he's
Disturbed that's true if someone has a
back tattoo like that they're they're
they have underlying issues I I think
you're right I think your decision on
what you're doing on yourself is like
such a big decision you know for people
but I follow you're gonna find a better
spot for that I follow some tattoo
artists that I love just because I love
to see it and I love their art and
there's like there's amazing tattoos you
could do today yeah yeah and this is
just like trash of the trashiest level
well this is incredible uh we found a
new rival but Ben Affleck is still
holding strong with 64 percent yeah and
uh congratulations Ben everybody and
also the backstory is super interesting
he lied about having it this Elite yeah
right the lies he said it wasn't him or
he doesn't have the tattoo yeah yeah it
was fake forget it said it was a fake
tattoo yeah right he said his face
it's a real tattoo and isn't that
embarrassing I think also what makes uh
Adam Levine like slightly better is that
that kind of look is a look for sure
yeah and it could be a cool look it just
made like awful decisions on what to put
there it's a pretty standard bad boy
yeah yeah
so I think it's um would you do you
think this is like Ben Affleck that's
it's not part of his look it's also it's
there's no story here like who are you
he had a midlife crisis yeah and that's
the story the California ruins it for me
yeah that's the worst part imagine
getting [ __ ] like New Hampshire
it's just so dumb right
it's like I mean look I like California
I love color foreign
[Music]
just right Earth bro that'd be more
that'd be cooler Earth
or maybe even maybe even if it was like
in calligraphy or some sort of like
interesting font like it's still bad but
it's just like it's just like times New
Rome in California
why is it so big too it's like the
centerpiece of his whole you know what I
love like did he immigrate here like did
he have a heart bringing up that like he
has such appreciation from no absolutely
not his parents very wealthy they
founded the story M Frederick you know
that story M Frederick oh so he comes
from money oh yeah and he grew up in
California oh yeah so like that he's
from Los Angeles it says because
California is like Utopia for me it's
like the perfect place on Earth and so
that just like you might as well just
write privilege yeah that's such a good
point you let this man it's not like a
special place in his heart where it
represents like his salvation
overcome of like some great he went
difficulty in life some private school
like some big name private school too
like he's you know
private school private school yeah
that's a very good point but uh the
people have spoken by the way I noticed
you guys did the poll the YouTube poll
on screen is that a new yeah well the so
being able to capture it and put it on
screen I have the capability to do that
with anything it's just for these simple
polls like this is fine to use the
YouTube one but the the problems with
the YouTube one is you only get four
options
um the characters are very limited and
it doesn't have all those fancy things
like being able to select multiple
options so okay when we have like a more
complicated poll use the straw poll but
for simple [ __ ] like this we'll just use
the YouTube stuff
somebody said that Tupac had the same
tattoo
his was a
it said Thug Life yeah yeah California
dude
how is that the same
it's not just yes
it's not so there it is um I have to pee
but moving on I don't know why those
tattoos get me so
uh we got the lizzo thing it's just oh
my God it's so fun but we have more
stuff at the top of the show I'm just
gonna go pee real fast right now uh go
ahead Eli you you host
well I saw a suggestion here you look I
think you probably did look at this back
in the day but people were saying why
don't you also compare let's do it
trigger warning trigger warning let me
know I'm sorry trigger warning trigger
warning
oh my God wait yeah I think we did uh it
looks like he has gotten a lot more
since we last talked about because here
this was the picture that I remember
talking about on the show he had just
this lion
oh dude his are awful but but now it's
like a whole piece so bad you know what
I'm saying though look at the look at
the
back
I'm gonna puke dude
yo
this is oh what
what's being accomplished here
it looks like a work in progress Where
It's Gonna Fill eight square with yeah I
suppose you're probably right about that
it's the back of a cereal box where he's
got to do yeah
instructions on how to wash
his back is like a wall in their picture
frames yeah like waiting to be filled I
guess that's the idea
man and then like his arms
like here's what's going on in his arm
it's just I don't hate I don't hate this
one as much Fresh Prince tattoo that's
kind of funny yeah I mean fortnite
huh
I think it's the colors are just so off
like it's too they just don't work I
don't know
everything that happens is from now now
on
oh
okay
and like this looks like one word so
it's like noun
yeah this is a contender in my opinion
yeah like this is this is real no I
think all right it's something that I do
see here though is like there it's a
there is a coherent
thing of like Madness
at least it's coherent though uh-huh
yeah
yeah like you said I mean it seems like
can we look at like Ben Affleck
photos
on the day today
I wonder if there's anything yeah
Affleck
back tattoo I wonder if there's any like
updated photos of it yeah people want to
pull
angry I'm so curious what what people
are thinking so to include to throw Ed
Sheeran in there him versus uh versus
Affleck yeah okay let me set that up
who's got
the worst tattoos
Ben Affleck Ed
year and
okay
here we go throwing it up I mean you see
Ben Affleck on the day today I think he
just like I can't pull a picture but if
you put it on it looks like you know he
dresses at the J crew or something
like what like just his his fashion
sense now yeah Ben Affleck uh
yeah I mean
this one picture is so funny hold on
what did you guys are not that one
that is so good wait the picture
over here with JLo wait that picture of
him on the beach was not what you were
looking for no she was just curious like
what his style is like nowadays because
we're talking we're talking about the
whole package right
okay
pretty seems pretty generic pretty
generic not nothing daring where did the
tattoo come from
dude I think midlife crisis is the real
explanation it really was sent 100 like
a freak out I think he actually like was
an alcoholic and went to rehab and stuff
I don't know about you yeah he's had
addiction issues he's a big Gambler too
oh
steak.com Ben Affleck yeah use code Ben
Affleck
um I gotta say
uh if you can throw up those poll
results
uh oh let me expand it so wait you guys
we did we looked at Ed wait Sharon's
while you're in the bathroom what well
reserve your uh judgment did he get new
ones they're so bad because I remember
we pit them together and he had the lion
one on his chest so the lion one has
been significantly expanded it's like a
whole chest it's like it's like in terms
of just but look at the drawing of a
lion it's very bad it's so bad
this is why this is why I think he's
he's losing what are you doing to your
body man oh it's his baby's feet I like
that that's what it is that's not bad
wait that's cool but I don't think we
realized that's what it was before you
came yeah but it's a frame with this
baby's feet he got other frames for
other moments to fill in
yeah you like it I mean I like first of
all it looks like [ __ ] obviously but I
like the sentimental approach of the
baby's feet on his back I think that's a
sweet thought let's show him the slave
uh close up I I thought that wasn't as
bad
uh yeah I mean it still looks
that's his sleeve yeah
everything that happens is from women
from now on this is now on but they like
didn't put enough of a gap between now
and alone it's probably because he wrote
it they're facing his everything that
happens is from now on whatever okay
cool dude
well the audience is breaking heavily uh
oh [ __ ] and then literally the chest
close-up again confused that you guys
are leaning towards Ed I mean that line
is unbeatable though yeah it's like what
who drew that
uh but there it is you guys say Ed I
mean okay that's what you want to do but
I just want to let you guys know yeah I
kind of start to feel like that lion is
just like you can't get past that
it's so bad
yeah okay well there it is guys uh
Ed Sheeran apparently
there's our is the worst uh tattoos ever
hey we have a um a special unexpected
guest who just dropped in really oh
really yes wait is your do you have
stuff in your mouth
yeah a little bit but they look swollen
without it or like Kanye right now after
the accident I looked like that too
after mine without anything in my mouth
really yeah yeah you have you have you
have cotton swabs yeah but it's still I
don't know you know what's the worst
yeah yeah yeah
some puffy cheeks you know what's the
worst part for me was that they give you
this syringe that you have to clean the
holes out it's so [ __ ] gross
yeah cause you have I got it you have
these holes they never told me to do
that oh Israel's crazy bro oh my God
you have four gaping holes yes and when
you eat food good stuff so they give you
a syringe you have to wash out though
they rinse it out yeah exactly that
exactly I never did that if you don't
you just have rotting festering food in
your holes oh
and then you you'd be surprised how much
[ __ ] falls out too you'd like do it over
the sink and it's just like all these
nasty bits you wanna know something
funny Ethan I had no idea what this was
for until you just told me oh
yeah
they did but he was out of it at the
time but they said not to use it
yesterday that I think like in a few
days or something that's why I didn't
explain it to him okay yeah make sure
you use that that's a good thing you got
any are you drugged up I'm feeling I'm
chilling right now I'm feeling good nice
was it Vicodin
uh it's Tylenol with Norco or with
codeine sorry Tylenol coding hell yeah
bro yeah
let's [ __ ] go how many they give you
they give me a good amount I'm not sure
exactly how many but let's find last
time I went under they gave me some but
it wasn't this much California is a lot
more lenient I feel like than Michigan
really I don't yeah maybe I don't know
doctors always
super stingy when I'm like suffering
here
really they're like here literally I
thought I broke my leg when I was in
Santa Cruz in college
I went to the hospital it was like the
worst spring ever my pain was like nine
out of ten constantly he gave me I swear
to God one Vicodin pill one oh wow yeah
I got 30. what let's [ __ ] party dude
I damn all right yeah there you go
something for the pain yeah Eli your
hair looks great by the way thank you
foreign
over
yeah that's kind of perfect yeah I just
it's kind of weird how they didn't calm
down or anything I've done anesthesia
before they're like counting down from
five oh are you sure they didn't
yeah and because last time I remember
like the start of it and then I just I
was out but this time nothing like they
were away they were like looked I was
looking at me I'm like wait is he and
then I just remember waking up after oh
my God that's interesting so crazy yeah
well it's done so good job done thank
you so are you are you in pain or the
pain meds it comes and goes yeah yeah
right now I'm chilling
good man yeah enjoy I don't want to
interrupt I'm just here to observe oh
you're on the show you're going to be on
the show
huh You're Gonna Be you're gonna stay on
the call yeah I'm just gonna hang around
okay yeah yeah enjoy the Michael Jordan
documentary or you know just have a good
time yeah thank you yeah of course did
you did you see the Ed Sheeran versus
Ben Affleck tattoos so no I was uh
setting this up I saw Ben verse Adam
Levine okay Ben one but now it's Ben
verse Ed Sheeran
well I think Ed Sheeran needs to give
some credit for being such a talented
artist right Kim I disagree no no I
think he's a good songwriter
cam really has a problem with Edge yeah
he's triggering I don't know what it is
dude but I don't think we're talking
about Talent yeah I just think he
doesn't take himself too seriously so he
get away with not as serious tattoos
that's a good point Levine are like
being very serious yeah
yeah he's not like a Chad type dude so
he has like Ninja Turtle tattoos and
[ __ ] like you know what yeah he has a
Fresh Prince of Bel Air it's kind of
funny I can't believe you all voted Ed
Sheeran that's [ __ ] up I believe it
the Chad did no I know I think it's
[ __ ] up that you guys did that all
right let's move on thank you baby nice
to see you God bless you all right take
care God bless God bless feel good all
right all I'm gonna say about Ed Sheeran
is you know he appeared on Game of
Thrones and then it went to [ __ ] make
that make up that much
killed it
actually I don't know if you guys
remember the chair drama we had with um
yeah with Dad did you follow that yes
yes so dad sent us a chair that was
apparently a gift for me that requires
like two hours of assembly
and so he came to the office oh he was
here to help assemble the chair
like he doesn't even included
[Applause]
dude he's going to be here any minute so
why do we even let him know yo that he's
coming back Beach dad
[ __ ] yo
oh hey hey look who the [ __ ] it is uh hi
Cameron nice to meet you I know I've
known who you are yeah nice to meet you
there's just so many people I forgot
to see you again
I didn't mean to disrespect it was going
to be a throne but it clearly is a pile
of How's that gonna be a throne yeah it
will yeah how is that going to be a
throne that was my thought yeah it's a
great question he genuinely expected us
to build this like that's not schtick
I was like what the [ __ ] there's none of
this is sticking don't waste time I'm
building this [ __ ] we got we have a show
to do
pick it up don't you see it pick it up
that being said you guys are kind of
overreacting it's not that serious no I
don't think so
yeah calmer than you dude common to you
would you just chill out man probably
you dude
promise [ __ ] you
still a big fan I love this [ __ ] out
yeah
he didn't deserve all that I'm sorry bye
guys [ __ ] you Dad
oh my God
it couldn't get any worse
you want this yeah you want you really
want it
oh my God
damn you guys are just being so ruthless
I mean I agree he's asking for it I
agree but you guys took it too far it's
a [ __ ] dude all right
well let's see if he redeems himself and
builds that Throne okay and we'll see
I'll be waiting if you have any update
or not yet no that was like a week ago
too radio silence what a surprise
clearly it's a big enough project for
him that in a week he hasn't completed
it I wouldn't put it past him to forget
yep
[Music]
chair was not not that bad comparing it
was great it existed it's fantastic
doesn't even exist it was a chair it's
infinitely better
by the nature of existing as you guys
know there was a huge hurricane in
Florida and as always happens during
these storms these [ __ ] weathermen
have it's time to prove their medal by
going and standing in a category for
Hurricane why do they do this we don't
know
uh we can click we know that it's windy
bro we can see that you know but here it
is this man is a
complete psychopath
oh
what oh this is so scary
to really [ __ ] things up right
now
why
Jeremy all right like what do you think
it's like yeah so uh
let me stand up yeah so thanks for
sending me out there guys
they're like listen Jim you know the
[ __ ] rules you get the easiest job
ever all you gotta do is stand in front
of a screen screen and point you some
[ __ ] 20 minutes a day but the deal
is when the hurricanes come around your
ass is going in the storm he's like guys
I don't want to go please you know the
[ __ ] rules Jim
150 mile per hour wind right there
oh my God it's like people are already
worried we don't need to also have to
worry about you we're trying to save
life Jeff get out of there yeah we're
not trying to add more casualties did
you guys hear about a GoPro I don't know
on a tripod and just leave something out
there yeah it's very windy or just look
out the window we see that it could just
be inside for for this whole thing
so funny yeah there's a bunch of them
here's another one
this one was actually terrifying
um
here is a time lapse
hurricane Ian how could you
of a fifth this is what a feet 15 foot
storm surge looks like
check it out it's pretty incredible and
also scary as hell
[Music]
it's a little windy doesn't seem that
bad
I'm sure everything will be fine I
wonder how close to the ocean oh my God
like that moment is just bananas yeah
but it gets so much worse the ocean's
just there
the ocean come to your town
actually even gets worse than this if
you can believe that
yeah oh my God there's choppy Waters
reaching the camera this house just I
buy a house gets oh my God
that is terrifying
I mean it's really [ __ ] crazy that
much water
that's just the ocean there's like fish
in there probably oh yeah it's gonna
happen is this gonna
what is the latest news I don't even
know it's out the water went back it
went back last I heard though once it
got out over the Atlantic it was picking
up steam again was heading for South
Carolina uh that was as of last night
hurricane let's see
yeah I there's just a lot of damage I
don't know how many casualties I was I
was listening to a report about it
I just wonder how he's doing
and hurricane named after him yeah Ian
how you doing he's not happy about it
uh
yeah
yeah he's having a wow he's like out of
it
is set to really [ __ ] things up right
now yeah
um oh I got some comments I want to read
Billy fishkin said thank you for the
gifted appreciate that a lot I went to
the bar in New York City where Ned from
try guys cheated it's near my school the
bartender said the downstairs room is a
celebrity Coke then and there's no
cameras allowed so they could have gone
down
but chose not to so they're at like a
celebrity Coke then where no cameras are
allowed
Ned him and him and then yeah it sounds
like it
uh out uh Axel uh womb womb little thank
you for the gifted it depends on how the
surgery is done mine was done in boot
camp for Navy
only bottoms
uh wisdom teeth yeah
people had tops and bottoms not sewn had
to rinse
I think mine was okay there it is Eli's
giving Khaleesi Vibes I would totally
follow her into battle says Ruby
remember for two years Ruby wow it's
gonna be one of the longest standing
ones Alex says uh thank you for the
gifted Ela racing the bar with the fresh
cut Demands a bold response from Ethan
bring back the broccoli assassin I'm
growing out my hair people because I'm
going on Jeff's Barber Shop yeah next
week or the week after I would like
afterwards while I'm still in this
blonde era I think you should maybe
maybe a blonde with me but when you're
ready
I don't know that I'm can sit for that
long today I was thinking if you do a
buzz and then bleach it it won't take as
long how come because it's just a buzz
like it's sure you want me to buzz and
bleach that sounds fun
I'm into it and then we can role play
that we're like cousins and then right
Pretend We're Targaryen yeah exactly
uh here's a before and after
I think this is kind of what you're
wondering oh wow no so this is before
awful of course it's a trailer park
whenever there's a natural disaster get
out of the trailer park yeah they're
always destroyed for some reason but
yeah they're all gone
and uh Fort Myers Beach
the morning
after oh my God that looks horrific yeah
that is just sad sad
but you know
Florida is just kind of inhospitable at
this moment I don't know unless
especially on the coastline
is it that close to Miami
uh this is on the west coast of Florida
so not super close I mean not like you
know it's the same state still obviously
but um this is the the Gulf Coast you
know on the western end of Florida that
got hit the hardest and this one it's
like a it's like a two and a half hour
drive from Miami yeah there you go
but you know Florida is pretty much
every year being absolutely
battered by Insane hurricanes
um at what point is it just not worth
building on the coastline there because
this is going to happen you know it's
gonna happen
within like 10 years guaranteed going to
happen
and um
I don't know maybe just her you know
what I mean it's just
doesn't seem like a good idea anymore
and it's only going to become more
frequent
well that's that's the update there
how many casualties I haven't seen the
number
if they're estimating
uh let's see but meanwhile
I've got to wrap it up I'm gonna queue
this up
[Music]
yeah this is your favorite you look
coming up next year the latest I'm
seeing is uh 21 and expected to grow
further
um
yeah I mean I think a big thing is uh a
lot of the disaster zones have not uh
been accessible until very recently so
that number will unfortunately
likely climb in the coming days I think
a lot of elderly people were trapped in
their houses too probably and which is
obviously super sad
but that's Florida you know uh so let's
get on to something more fun well look
at this crying buffoon there's there's
two giant [ __ ] in one spot Pierce
Morgan and Jordan Peterson
bro what the f have you ever seen this
from the same
where we saw the outer clip last
no this is fresh I think
yeah this is fresh
have you ever seen a more English
looking person in your life like look at
this man he is just he is hot dog red
yeah that might be right I think we did
watch it right there's a bit of a
selection of this interview it was just
like a Hitler and everyone yeah exactly
yeah yeah yeah yeah and that's weird
then because I don't know why this one
suddenly went viral like just this week
and but anyway here it is um Jordan
Peterson maybe it came out in Parts is
that possible maybe a preview would come
out the Hitler part was at the very
beginning so I think that went around
first in the interview nobody sat
through it this was uploaded two days
ago two days ago yeah no it definitely
had a second round of uh virality this
week well regardless here it is uh
Jordan Peterson crying
over Olivia Wilde's in-cell comparison
my goodness the the humanity
well why not here I don't want to but I
have to uh what I'll ask you just
quickly uh the film director Olivia
Wilde has a new movie out she says it's
based on you this insane man this
pseudo-intellectual hero to the in-cell
community in cell being these weirdo
loner men uh who are not expectable in
many ways is that you are you the
intellectual here for these people
sure why not you know
um
people have been after me for a long
time by because I've been speaking to
disaffected young men you know what a
terrible thing to do that is again first
this part makes me roll my eyes so hard
nobody's [ __ ] saying that they don't
want disaffected young men to be a talk
to what a terrible thing that is how
dare I talk to young men
and tell them that trans people are
ruining Society
what a terrible thing that is to say
that conversion therapy is a good choice
I like how he's like people have been
after me but like he's saying stuff like
that that are actually harmful that's it
that's what I'm saying but then he
conflates it by saying well all I want
to do is talk to they're mad because
he's talking to young men not because of
what he's saying
uh oh Waterworks is coming
oh
okay let's get together Jordan I thought
the marginalized we're supposed to have
a voice bro
the [ __ ] March the the white men yeah
the Wasps they need a voice
it's been too long that straight white
men haven't had a voice in society
well God forbid
the marginalized men
do you know what it's like to grow up
straight white and catholic christian
whatever
how do you unlock this ability to cry
over nothing
like it sounds like he's crying every
time now yeah he think he's just really
unstable like I said when I was super
unstable I would cry right like too much
in my opinion I think it's just he's
very emotional not healthily
God forbid
I thought the marginalized were supposed
to have a voice
my young white straight men where's
their voice the most oppressive group
when when did they finally speak gamers
also bro you're literally listen how
he's playing up this [ __ ] victim
mentality for young white men you're
making them feel they're a victim now
what kind of [ __ ] self-advice help
advice is that the one who's going after
Elliot page right
so shut up
a grown ass person sound like that Zack
shut up Buckle right I mean where were
the trans people when they were
corrupting the youth they're all
groomers
where's our voice the young what the
white straight men of America
what happened to the marginalized you
[ __ ] Hypocrites said the trans people
should be protected what about straight
white men
oh God
it's making emotional talk about it well
God you know
it's very difficult to understand
by the way people go oh you guys are
such [ __ ] Hypocrites because you say
that men should be more emotional and
sensitive and here he is crying and then
you're making fun of him like you and
it's like bro I'm not making fun of him
for crying no it's it's what he's crying
about right
and also the serial crying I was going
to say it's yeah it's more about the
frequency yeah because yeah no of course
it's okay for men to cry and that should
be more encouraged but maybe not every
conversation
quite literally
Pinocchio was disaffected I think that
might just be a little too much he went
to the island of pleasure
and the donkeys they kept him there you
know just like the three the seven
dwarves
came marching out of that cave man
they were fined in God in those jewels
those diamonds
and you know they wanted to train we're
on train on that [ __ ] but they didn't
and that's what's so powerful about the
dwarves they had they had they held
their desires at Bay LOL
it makes me tear up inside when I think
of those seven dwarves and their blue
balls
Dan what are the comments on this video
oh that's a great question uh they're
shatteringly insightful comments yeah
it's it's here's the top one a 10 000
points it saddens me to see how we treat
each other I stand with you Mr Peterson
I'm in pain
[Laughter]
he's he really saw it as I'm trying to
help these people become functional
members of society I'm getting pinned as
evil for it how does helping people
become better suddenly turn someone
who's probably saved countless lives
into a villain by many he was a
significant more support from everyone
it's just the same old [ __ ] it's
like a cold at this point it's really
crazy here's one that I like though tell
me what you they're they're quoting
something he says in this video yeah
quote people make their mistakes as they
stumble uphill
what a quote
that's the comment he didn't invent that
before yeah
and it's not I don't know I don't find
that that insightful like that that
didn't blow my mind uh people people
okay let's just watch I'm trying to do
more wise people are
and certainly many young men are in that
category and you get these casual
insults these these Ends by the way I
pause too much I know but like first of
all there is a problem with this
affected young men there is that's why
you're seeing all this craziness but I
don't think someone who's gonna take
them under their wing
and then teach them that they're the
real victims the real marginalized group
that's just whatever happened to
self-help self-reliance bootstrapping
yourself sitting there and crying about
your own [ __ ] suffering is beta [ __ ]
subprime a loser next says what does it
mean it's like could these men they're
they don't know how to make themselves
attractive to women who are very picky
and good for them women like be picky
that's that's your gift man
everybody wants to [ __ ] you and you just
gotta Ward them off what was that term
that he was talking about that women
should just have to like get in a
relationship with an insult monogamy
yeah Force monogamy
you know
and that's your gift ladies you've got
it easy
women have it so [ __ ] easy
he's playing into the insult mentality
yeah literally what they say it
literally doesn't make any [ __ ] sense
there's there's an equal amount of men
and women out there
getting all the [ __ ] play right it
like men and in particular these in
cells I mean that's one of the biggest
things is that they're way too [ __ ]
picky especially for the amount of
effort that they put into bettering
themselves which is usually nil like
they are not desirable and yet they have
this expectation that you know they
deserve a 10 everybody deserves a 10.
come to join us and together we'll end
women
here's two columnists uh we must protect
this man at all costs some see his
empathy and emotions as weakness to me
it shows his Valor Valor Valor
he's been playing too many video games
uh he really is a kind-hearted man who
feels deeply for the people he's trying
to help yeah again he's yeah and he
feels horribly for like
other people and he has no problem
preaching hate towards them like I'm
sorry but that tweet that he got banned
over or yeah that was just insane it was
so cruel so cruel how are you gonna talk
about like wanting to help people if you
want to talk about a marginalized group
let's talk about trans people not
straight white men
right
I mean what but again I just can't get
over the fact that he's basically doing
in-cell gospel now so you definitely are
the hero men women are so selective
and that's for the right God bless them
I'm women like be picky that's that's
your gift man it's a gift demand high
standards from your men as in they were
born with this innate they're born with
this innate upper hand it's their gift
what's up
but all these men who are alienated it's
like
they're Lonesome and and and they don't
know what to do and everything
alienated because they can't get laid in
this Society we're women can't even do
abortions if they want to
alien alienation is when can't get laid
Yeah
because you're a weirdo probably
let's just go back to women uh not being
able to vote
mm-hmm you're a weirdo bro
oh also he goes that's your gift it's
like you know they have to have be
pregnant and give birth to children too
right is that also their gift
you know
which I would totally do if it was my
option you know I would like totally do
that if only you could yeah if only yeah
I can't young men there's no need to
feel down I said young man pick yourself
off the ground I said young man because
you're in a new town there's no need to
be unhappy
so deep
when she said that Olivia Wilde it bit
stung you didn't it I saw this oh by
that time you know that as far as as
critic critiques go that was kind of low
level I mean once I got painted as
Red Skull you know magical super Nazi
it's kind of the end of the insults who
said magic there's no place I think Red
Skull is I mean he's a super villain I
don't know much about it
is he magical Red Skull uh it's some
like Nazi occult stuff he's the bad guy
in Captain America right oh yeah don't
get him started on Sports Illustrated
models right yeah is it also their gift
to conform to your very narrow beauty
standards which is uh apparently sorry
not beautiful yeah did you forget what
you [ __ ] are you piece of [ __ ]
judgmental loser people are making me to
be this evil guy you are literally just
an Intel that happened to get married
somehow
damn man he's passed out so when Olivia
Wilde made those comments first thing I
did was go look at the preview for her
movie which I quite liked I thought I
would go see that movie probably and
perhaps I will it didn't really bother
me my my family and I talked about it
right away and we were able to respond
to it with some degree of humor which
then people completely misunderstood I
said I hope that you know that if I had
to be played by someone I think Chris
Wilde is that
he's a very good looking man and so yeah
right you know and then I said something
like I hope he gets my my uh fashion
style choice right when
I felt like I went home and we brought
all of our great minds together to
answer with humor
and we said Chris Wilding hope I'm
played by Chris Wilding
handsome man turned into Joe Biden
handsome man
looking like me get my style straight
Jack got her legs
Jordan's impeccable style one
you never seen that no that's how that
was Jordan before uh before the Jordan
that we know and that [ __ ] used
to walk around with a feather and his
cat oh right straight up forgot about
the feather uh oh God I forgot that song
crocodile
what's that song that we learned as kids
with the feather in the cap
e dude oh Yankee Doodle Yankee Doodle
looking ass
he ain't no Yankee though you know he's
a southern boy
mm-hmm well technically he's a northern
boy no he's fighting for the foreign the
great night white North well he's not
even American so [ __ ] him and it was a
joke oh that was a joke
you've been so controlled today
and yet in that brief moment you got
very emotional why
well you know I only eat meat that
really messes with my emotions I've been
off my
my site my uh
psychiatric medicine since I started
eating meat that hasn't helped
and I'll tell you I dream of benzos
and I took I did have a shot of apple
cider five years ago I haven't been
right since
it's really something to see
oh
not again
oh my God
how many people
are dying for a lack of an encouraging
word
[Music]
what about Ellie what are you talking
about what about Elliot page yes he's
he's talking about suicides yes he's
talking about suicide he says people are
dying for one encouraging word
[ __ ] trans people yeah for
example bro if you had such a bleeding
heart yeah
maybe just don't go out there calling
people ugly for no reason like what
I forget what did he say about Elliot
page it was so vile I don't even
remember one tweet was discussed we
actually have to pull it up I got to
give context here uh thank you Henry for
thank you for gifted uh hello Ethan Ela
and the crew on Tuesday I was diagnosed
with APL oh no leukemia I was a 20 year
old college student as hard as this
process is going to be
I just asked for all you to keep making
me laugh for the next couple months man
I'm so sorry yeah but don't yeah I'm
sorry for what you're going through but
try not to ask too much for me okay
buddy we don't even know each other
you want me to keep doing this show for
a couple months you're gonna have to
donate more than 20 bucks
just kidding obviously uh you are uh man
that sucks man just
go [ __ ] get give it hell dude Henry
give it hell
[ __ ] bro
you're 20 years old your buddy is still
super young and strong super buddy yeah
you can fight it
well it could be worse you could be uh
Ellen Page remember when Pride was a sin
oh yeah he says about uh gay pride this
is a dumbest thing and Alan Page just
had her breasts removed by a criminal
physician this dude is out of his
[ __ ] mind and here he's crying about
compassion calling the doctor criminal
I'm sorry I mean if Pierce Morgan was
worth it an ounce of journalistic
Integrity he would bring that up right
now he's like why'd you say this
Criminal
get him in that vulnerable moment to
explain himself
dude
dude and how easy it is to provide that
if you're careful
you know give credit where credit is due
the only people I like to encourage is
white straight males
fat women are [ __ ] Abominations I
talk about them regularly
don't get me started on trans people
disgusting freaks
but I really want I'm here today to
focus on the marginalized white straight
men
Call of Duty players I wish somebody
would encourage them just one voice of
encouragement
[Music]
yeah
I don't like black folks either they'll
find their own leaders
I'm just really focused on white
straight men
[Music]
where's their words of encouragement and
women have this gift they could [ __ ]
whoever they want it's men it's man
moment
they can [ __ ] anyone
and some do those slots
but men oh God forbid they've been
forgotten do you know how hard it is to
land a tent
men be settling for seven sixes God
forbid fives
but I'll tell you what man nobody wants
to [ __ ] a three
those threes need to work on themselves
they could easily become a four or five
if they worked on themselves
man they're disgusting nothing worse
than a fat chick
anyway
if only
also like how is he gonna talk about our
privilege to put down men when we're
coming off of stuff like me too and all
this this [ __ ] is vacuuming
sorry Gila but
why is he vacuuming right now Lena
oh I just looked at the see I'm looked
at the zoo is he on speed or also I'm
kind of curious what is he wearing yeah
it's some sort of
does he doesn't know we're watching oh
he does it's like a lot
I was wondering why he was wearing that
it's like a lingerie robe
um someone gifted it to me at our
wedding I don't know who but it's so
comfortable and I love wearing it
um yeah it's really really soft so I'm
guessing that's why yeah I left my robe
in Michigan
I left my robe in Michigan
all right Jordan let's do this to him
and to say
I just don't understand this whole thing
about like oh we have so much privilege
we can pick and choose who we date it's
like how about
all the abuse that women have and
harassment like don't care
you deserve it for being choosy what is
he talking about I just you don't even
understand you alienate so much Men by
not letting them [ __ ] you do you
understand the harm that does right but
I don't care about that
dude Jordan Peterson is straight Gilead
Vibes like hardcore man
crazy yeah
you're in that Force for good if you
want to be
oh shut up
do you believe your net falsely good
net yes in all the details probably not
that what I thought was a cur that was a
very self-aware moment there I was kind
of taken aback by that
I don't know why he says net good
and all the details no like what what
well let's hear him explain I'm curious
do you believe you're a net force for
good
net yes
in all the details probably not
you know no one's perfect
so oh he's just no one's perfect
yeah he just he he just he did yeah but
he's perfect on us
yeah but if you believe that you are a
net negative to the world maybe you
should stop trying to tell people how to
live their lives no he said good he said
not good yeah he's good
right but then he answered no to that is
that in the details no because nobody's
perfect yeah but net mean that no net he
said good
um okay and the details Nobody's Perfect
Jordan's been a fascinating interview
thank you very much
you've thank you you've got this new box
set up yeah yeah I'm pretty happy about
that would be just 24 rules for life uh
and [ __ ] more rules oh God we've sold
how many millions now
there it is
so good
what roles you sons of pictures what
rules tons of [ __ ] what rules
you sons of Bishops [ __ ] at seven and I
think bro you gotta wipe your nose this
is not coming down his [ __ ] face like
get your [ __ ] together you're
embarrassing look at this it's a mess
you're a mess man
you are such a mess get your [ __ ]
life together bro oh God get your own
house in order it's literally rule
number one in your book actually it
might not be literally number one but
it's one of the rules I've got this new
book called The 613 mids foes
rule number one it's called the Toro
don't [ __ ] your sister
that one's easy enough the Jews yeah we
can lock it up there thank you Jordan so
thank you
always a pleasure always a pleasure I
hope you found that tissue
oh let's talk about the Liza thing
because we're getting kind of
lizzo
what'd I say Liza it's a gift man Liza
Minnelli everybody lizzo
lizzo first of all okay so let's talk
about lizzo this you guys it's probably
gonna piss you off it's certain my mind
was just perpetually blown so just try
to go into this with like a a good sense
of humor okay you know just try to see
this as
some stupid silly [ __ ] it's a good Smoky
flavor I mean it's
the people that we're gonna go over that
are mad about this are
this this controversy has not got
traction like they are alone in being
upset about this so we can no but these
are the these are the prominent
conservative voices in media yeah and
they have a ton of support on social
media when they doing this
so it seemed like this wasn't really
hidden for Their audience from when I
was they all well I mean it was to an
extent for sure you're right I looked at
the comments people were behind them man
yeah all right so conservatives are
losing their [ __ ] because lizzo was
playing a 200 year old Crystal flute
owned by
fourth president United States James
Madison it all started off when the
Library of Congress librarian tweeted
out inviting lizzo who is a classically
trained flutist who often placed the
flute during her show which is pretty
dope bro who among us could bust out a
flute
you know what I mean
damn so they invited her directly to
visit the museum when she was in DC for
a concert the museum now this is
important reached out
the Library of Congress hey lizzo
we have a collection uh has the largest
food collection in the world with more
than 1800 including President James
Madison 1813 Crystal flute Liza would
love for you to come
[ __ ] just you guys know what I mean just
you know what I means it Liz though we
would love for you guys to come see it
even play a couple when you are in DC
next week
like song like your song they are good
as hell she was invited to do it
explicitly invited okay by an official
14th librarian of Congress okay this
woman is this is her [ __ ] job she's a
historian and this is a formal
invitation to come and play one of these
flutes look at this fluke man
so cool a lot of flutes I mean that's
just one wall and it's the biggest fluke
collection I mean I just tells you
there's not people aren't really
collecting flutes out there
foreign
are you disparaging the size of their
fluke collection I mean I mean when you
hear largest in the world usually it's
more than flutes are very small you can
pack a lot into a drawer you know I
thought this was very impressive it is
it is it is it's the biggest in the
world
you know
uh but check out these flutes flutes of
all sizes all colors
all kinds of different uh situations and
and that's a very formal
invitation
uh next up here's the video
uh of La so lizzo got the Tweet yeah I
almost said I expect myself so Lindo saw
the Tweet she's in DC for a concert
here's this is tweeted out by Library of
Congress okay
and they said hearing lizzo play some of
the library's priceless priceless
antique instruments on Monday was such a
gift and we were honored and happy to
help her share that gift with her
concert audience Tuesday night here's
some more behind the scenes footage of
her Library tour let's enjoy this
the U.S premiere of this piece happened
in the pool of janitorium audio audio
and this is the flute
okay uh I can play it or no yeah
right that's what I don't know oh
[Music]
[Applause]
wow dude she shreds
[Music]
I love her yeah dude she's like this is
high level uh classical playing right so
she can read sheet music she can
she has a lot of like
theoretical music down
you say what just a random Flocka
[Music]
you know what I think it'd be
I think it
is that UAB
[Music]
maybe what
disrespectful to the flutes bro
you gotta respect the flute exactly yeah
she's great that's great it's super cool
super impressive I didn't know that I
also side note I love her outfit here
she's so cool she is very cool uh lizzo
so
this actually was you know 134 000 likes
so it's pretty cool even for the Library
of Congress someone who's probably not
getting a lot of interest from the
public is now uh getting a lot of
attention on their tweets I mean how
could that be a bad thing right
uh the next night handlers from the
museum brought a flute to her on stage
during her show here it is
nobody has ever heard this famous
Crystal flute before
now you have I'm the first and only
person to ever play this presidential
200 year old Crystal flute thank you at
Library of Congress
so this has four million views 175 000
likes
um it's pretty cool for the Library of
Congress it's pretty cool for her it's
like a good moment
[Applause]
[Music]
the flute is super cool it's like made
of crystal
it was owned by like kings and
presidents and heads of state
I guess it's like some kind of a
technological Marvel I I can't imagine
that's gonna be so stressful Do not drop
it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah pretty cool right yeah fun yeah
also super respectful to the fluid
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
being super respectful of the flu
actually promoting
yeah you guys want me to stop every time
and just wait pause for laughter you can
do that it's a skill it really is it's a
gift you have I'll pause for laughter
guys go ahead
laughs
yeah so anyway
um lizzo very respectful yeah in
collaboration with the Library of
Congress even I think her ultimate
thrust where there was like history's
awesome yeah y'all should be interested
in history more check out what's going
on at the Library of Congress right
I mean if anything she's gonna make
flutes even cooler you know yes so so
going over that
now what is your kind of snap take from
that whole situation my take is that I
love her even more than I then I did
anyone else have a snap take from that
whole thing it was cool man yeah I
wouldn't have even known that flute
existed if it wasn't for this
what you don't know about James
Madison's 200 year old Crystal flute
that's basically that that's the Holy
Grail of American History right take her
passport away yeah did you know of it
did anyone no [ __ ] no nobody knew about
this Crystal flute it's like the most
obscure thing you could possibly [ __ ]
imagine well James Madison didn't play
the flute it was just like a gift yeah
he never he didn't even play it it was
just like a gift that uh yeah it was
like some French ornament yeah in 1813
uh made for Madison in honor of his
second inauguration
uh it says it's possible that the flute
was one of a handful of valuables that
the former first lady took with her
while the White House
uh burned down uh from British troops in
1814
uh the guy who made it anyway it's it's
his flute whatever they should just give
it to her permanently yeah better hands
now
well anyway like yeah my reaction to
that is just like it was wholesome it
was fun it was cool
I didn't know she played the flute like
that was dope
well okay
here we go Tim pool first of course Tim
pool this guy this man takes himself
seriously I wanna I wanna call you man
absolutely I want to encourage you guys
to understand how serious this man takes
himself
all of it now that sword and a gun thing
on the wall I know he thinks he's a
[ __ ] pirate it's embarrassing
all right here we go and improve moving
forward but when I see something like
this I don't I don't feel like Rage or
disgust I just kind of I kind of feel
like yeah we're going down we're going
downhill because there's there's a
certain amount of respect you would have
for objects and artifacts and things
that represent the successes and and the
failures of humanity and for this
spectacle of this big you know what's
the right word bodacious Bodacious sure
Loop but look look I'm not trying to be
mean to to lizzo because you know I'm
fairly he's calling her fat buddy yeah
yeah he how's that disrespectful right
no he's the fact that lady bad yeah
there's a lot of but you're gonna see
here but in Spike but what I see here is
American history being mocked
essentially by a morbidly obese woman on
stage
as a joke totally disrespecting what it
is what it represents what it's supposed
to be
yeah yeah does he know what American
look like because like how is that being
disrespectful to America yeah what they
all somehow make a point of mentioning
she's morbidly obese the very nature of
a fat person holding that flu is an
Abomination to this country that's
insane
yeah it's pretty wild that's disgusting
I mean that's just like disgusting okay
it's just really embarrassing that's the
one thing they took from that clip
yeah I mean it gets worse actually if
you can believe that and as Luke was
saying it's it's the normalization all
of all of these really negative traits
that we're supposed to be okay with I
look at this and I feel like it's
idiocracy I feel like it's Wally you
know in Wally everybody's morbidly obese
they have no bone density anymore that's
that's not the kind of place we want to
go we don't want to go into some future
where everyone's like He-Man ripped and
like it's sparred or anything like how
the [ __ ] did lizzo playing the flute
turn into a commentary about like all
obese people in society
um Temple she has more [ __ ] talent
and originally in her one of her little
flute playing pinky fingers then you
have under that yeah vacant beanie empty
[ __ ] head ears you're such a loser
bro I don't know Tim's music career is
you know next level oh that's true this
song is so [ __ ] good yeah that's so
disgusting yeah and usually Tim is more
I not to compliment he's a piece of [ __ ]
but like if you compare him to like
Crowder or Ben Shapiro he's usually
tries to be more serious but when I see
something like this supposed to be okay
with I look at this and I feel like it's
idiocracy I feel like it's Wally you
know how is how is someone playing a
beautiful classically trained fluid
idiocracy wouldn't that be like the
antithesis to that
and I mean you sitting there pretending
to [ __ ] know anything about it is
idiocracy your wall is idiocracy I mean
your whole existence
tell you everybody's morbidly obese they
have no bone density anymore in the
yeah you don't think it's Katana does
the future
He-Man ripped and like it's sparred or
anything like that but the very least we
can be like hey you know we're gonna
respect the the a relics of our past so
we can understand it literally says to
me is just like taking a dump on the
American flag you know
taking a dump she literally said she's
respecting the history she said history
is cool why is he talking about it
because they're so they're angry that a
obese black woman
got to me they didn't even put in two
seconds to understand that actually she
was treating with a lot of respect a lot
of respect uh and care and actually as a
classically is that on YouTube this show
yeah yeah he's huge on YouTube
that's his main thing uh they're just I
mean how how else can you interpret that
other than like
you know what you know what the problem
is though it's definitely not me
it's how do you interpret that as
anything other than like racism because
like there's no explanation or fat
phobia too
for for that response because the
response is totally detached from
reality he goes on by the way so he's
saying that fat
are not allowed to
they
I'm gonna I'm gonna tell you what
they're saying this is I don't agree
with this at all
it's the fact that she was in a
revealing outfit and that she shook her
ass while she was holding the thing that
they've really honed in on as being an
Abomination like he said the criticism
would become more clear as we go through
I got suspended again by the way you
guys want to see what part oh boy
let's see
hateful Behavior this time nice no that
concludes attacks threatening and incite
inciting violence [ __ ] yes
thank you Tater Tots you guys are
something else man
does he get views on this show yeah no
he's very popular
Temple very popular
super popular like how many views does
this have on YouTube I'll tell you that
episode
let's see was that well these are the
same people that think Jordan Peterson's
a great [ __ ] thinker also watching
Temple rant about lizzo with a flute his
full episode of his Tim cast and then
they chop it up into like a million
Clips so it's
a little advice to him if you see this
as separate highlights Channel
really really clutter cluttering up the
feet here uh it looks like between like
uh 250 000 on like an average app and
then some of them are a decent amount
higher than that 400 000. it's gone down
because I remember during the election
he was pulling a million per yeah I
actually was expecting it to be higher
um
it's not that impressive right now but
it's still a lot you know I mean that
hurt 200 300 000 average it looks like
Well here here's a here he expands like
that was never played before was a
historical artifact was handed off to
some Entertainer to play on stage and
that's why I said desecration
it's it's it's do you work for the
Library of Congress or something like a
historical librarian whose sole
responsibility is handling those thought
it was fine so who the [ __ ] are you
sitting there in your little [ __ ]
trailer with pirate memorabilia on the
wall and a literally hole in the [ __ ]
top of your brain to say that it's a
desecration it's not the Constitution
bro it's a [ __ ] flute you didn't even
know existed that was before the day
that was why I like flipped out earlier
stupid I guess without the context of
seeing what they're all saying that's
what I was trying to say no nobody knows
about this flute it's like yeah other
than like hard hardcore history nerds
you know what I mean flute people I I
suppose but this is not yeah like you
said it's not the Constitution this
isn't like some famous thing yeah God
it's so Madding that's what I was saying
I was trying to warn you guys yeah that
is it's pretty crazy painful painful
painful oh she has a whole Instagram
page dedicated to playing flute
I mean
I think she's in maybe an authority on
the subject even
him as a white man though also somebody
said she's also very healthy exercises
and is vegan
she's vegan she's vegan shut up so
well um
as Tim as a straight white male uh
his his take is obviously heavier as a
marginal we need to elevate marginalized
voices for sure yeah
[Music]
here is a lizzo desecrating another
flute guys
[Music]
he touches it's just disrespectful yep
lock her in a cage yeah just kill her
uh that was a joke for the record yes
I'm just a joke here fellas
not a serious threat actually
I was speaking hypothetically of what
they might think yes long live lizzo in
fact
rewind time
Crystal flute that was ornamental it is
now a gag prop for for a state show it's
not like [ __ ] are you serious American
flag I mean she just like played a flute
for five seconds I mean it's I I
wouldn't necessarily call it desecration
I would say the whole situation is like
I'm not I'm trying I'm not trying to say
that it's like akin to like pissing on a
grave or anything sounds like it it has
fundamentally altered what that object
was oh and I just think what we see
consist instantly is this this idea that
these people he said it was like
[ __ ] on the American flag yeah he
literally said that yeah yeah you're
right he goes he literally said that
before
dude I just can't get over these people
they're it's so transparently pathetic
it's just
so insane you guys
it's a [ __ ] flute
that you didn't know existed talented
person handling it exactly what are you
talking like Carrot Top took it on stage
and farted on it or something I I
couldn't think of somebody better
deserving would do that she handled it
very carefully respectfully
absolutely nothing for this country they
call it historically racist they crap
all over it and it's all hypocrisy well
just just to be clear not that I'm
saying it is a political statement but
but the guy who owned the flu
uh uh uh Madison was a pro-slavery
Southern
uh plantations dude I mean the guy
was a big slave guy he was one of the
big slave guys it's the author of The
Three-Fifths Compromise oh well there
you go that's a great one what's that
that was a constitutional amendment that
said
for the purpose of sense the census
that three slaves
out of five equals one white guy
one white person
three-fifths baby oh my God that was a
good one that was a good one
for the purpose of uh
for the purpose of allocating
representatives in Congress essentially
which before they didn't come for
anything so I guess that you know hey
shout out really sensitive you know
three-fifths baby happy to say defund
the police but then call the police on
people they don't like they're more than
happy to to all laugh and cheer and
scream 1619 project but then be like
whoo we get to play with it we watched
the same clip she just played the flute
for two seconds yep
historical artifact it's just what I see
is you can certainly look to the Past in
your country and and and say hey there
were bad things and we want to do away
with those but I think you absolutely
have to respect you know the beginnings
of where you come from and the history
of your country I think look what it
comes down to is the reverence for this
country is is just flushed on the toilet
and this is this may just be a grain of
sand in the Heap but this is like a big
show where they pulled from the archives
from the Library of Congress and brought
it on stage to make some spectacle out
of I'm not saying it's the apocalypse
but it's not I'm not like significant
either that the actual flu like you know
we don't we don't know what it's
even his own crew is like a [ __ ] I
don't think that's relevant
yeah it's not relevant it's not it's
about it's even less relevant than the
flute itself
uh congratulations to rockumentary uh
just got married
congrats God bless God bless God bless
yeah love that and then here's of course
Sam Cedar shutting these really negative
in a little edits it's the normalization
all of all of these really negative
traits that we're supposed to be okay
with lying now look at this and I feel
like it's idiocracy I feel like it's
Wally you know in Wally everybody's
morbidly obese they have no bone density
anymore that's that's not the kind of
place we want to go
I don't care it's it's the normal the
origin he debated Temple and absolutely
eviscerated him Temple started going on
some weird tangent about Thanos he was
trying to use Thanos as a uh
he was saying that kind of allegory he
was saying that Sam Cedar's uh
philosophy is akin to Thanos and Sam
theater was like I don't know what
you're talking about he's like I haven't
seen anything that you're talking about
I don't care I don't know I don't care
his whole world view was the Disney
franchise exactly and that that's why
that was such a great edit because he's
like just everything's a movie so that's
just Tim Paul we're moving on to Jenna
or yeah who's a representative's aide
Doug mastriano
um and I think that it sounds like he's
Italian and I would think as a margin
another marginalized group
so true
uh Andy's yeah
he's a white Italian man I can't think
of anything more you should have more
does he play Call of Duty he probably
does it's a triple threat responsibly 30
days 30 minutes a night only right so
here she is she's claiming that uh lizzo
is basically famous I think for being
one of the most morbidly obese people in
the world um in God and said of the
Madison flute playing this is just
desecration purposefully of the American
history so let's go on by the way and
I'm not wonderful but why why is this
late
lady like putting all of Lisa's
accomplishments into the trash like what
is she talking about
who are you also and I mean listen I'm
not one to like
call someone fat I mean I'm fat and I
respect people of all sizes but I mean
if she's going to be going out on lizzo
being morbidly obese I mean stand up and
do a tour you're not that [ __ ] skinny
just insane
you know eat your own kind damn have
some fat acceptance
in just the last sorry two minutes that
I have
with you uh Ryan I want
I want to turn to this you know
you know culture pop culture story about
lizzo and this is just I think a
beautiful example
and a perfect example
um it's actually you know hideous but I
say it's beautiful and in a rhetorical
sense because
um of pop culture and just where the
left is looking to shape and move our
country so what happened if you haven't
watched the video
um do so at your own risk because you
know
can you these people are not serious
how do we share a political fear how do
we share a country with them and then we
share oxygen I'm just so flabbergasted
by this did you all see the same clip as
me I don't know it's like you saw her
taking it and like smashing it on the
floor like a Jimi Hendrix concert or
some [ __ ]
thanks for being one of the most
morbidly obese people in the world [ __ ]
but why aren't they focusing on that
she's a she's like an amazing musician
how but how does that have to do with
anything Super Famous she has a lot of
really good music like what are they
talking and she's a classically trained
flute player but why are they talking
about like she's just famous for being
obese it has literally it has zero
relevance her weight her body and again
if we're just discrediting fat people
leave the room you're [ __ ] fat
I'm just saying like who you're you're
undermining your own self leave the
[ __ ] room if we're not listening to
fatties get out
I'm just saying
you know
and move our country so what happened if
you haven't watched the video
um do so at your own risk because you
know blizzo is basically famous I think
for being one of the most morbidly obese
people in the world who claims that
she's oppressed and yet you know she's
like a multi-millionaire and
um you know very famous but she gets on
having money she's very famous and what
this [ __ ] is so I'm sorry again I hate
that this [ __ ] is intolerable you are
such a nasty [ __ ] [ __ ]
Colleen man
[ __ ] yeah they're seeing how like lizzo
um uh it's disrespectful for her to have
played that and they're being so like
the way they're talking about her is
also very trashy and and gross yeah it's
a thousand times trashier than anything
she did he didn't do anything yeah
yeah you're so right they're so
unself-aware I just can't I can't I
don't know if you can call her a [ __ ]
though she is a [ __ ]
point of view
when I like if you see a guy an annoying
guy that disagree is with you or
something and then he calls you a [ __ ]
you know it's kind of like I wouldn't be
okay with that yeah yeah I mean if it
was being said to me like
I don't know are you asking in this
context of Ethan in this context should
he not say should he not call her a
[ __ ] what do you think Sam oh here we
go okay I'm all ears oh I will bow to
the council as well
if I can offer a defense well you know
why'd you put me here let me speak in my
defense and then you guys can roll I'm
kidding I'm kidding no it's a good
conversation in my defense it's because
I don't like saying that right I don't
use that word lightly and I don't like
saying it that when I whip it out for a
[ __ ] bile [ __ ] like this that has
that impact and she's she's not she's
but but that that's my point and then
you you guys can uh rule because if I
will see a team fool calling some uh
somebody disagrees with a [ __ ] you're
like oh look at this nasty yeah fair
enough I don't want people to see you
like that the difference between me and
Tim pools I'm right
people want to pull do you guys trust a
poll yeah
it doesn't hurt to take a temp check the
thing is like she is maybe it's not that
serious that's why I do want to hear
opinions because maybe it's it's fine so
is the poll
can Ethan call her a bee or is she a b
was no no no right to call her a [ __ ]
in general should Ethan even use that
word
I think we need to do more situation in
and derogatory hold on you don't think
this is a good poll was Ethan right to
call her a [ __ ] no no
no here with peace
as a woman yeah she's being a [ __ ] yes
but you're a woman okay it's a woman's
word but the thing you get you get the
the the f word pass uh the the fat pass
man you you know you were able to call
her out on that but maybe not the bee
past you know the thing about it maybe
it's just me I don't know no it's a good
conversation to have I don't like saying
it and sometimes I wonder
the thing about her is the way that
she's physically attacking her
appearance she's going for the lowest
possible uh route when talking about her
it's like bottom of the barrel [ __ ] here
but maybe I shouldn't say it I don't
like saying it but go ahead let's do the
pull
I need I still need Clarity because it
didn't seem like you guys were on the
sweatpage Ethan ever say [ __ ] in any
comment like a derogatory way yeah
or the woman towards a woman I feel like
that it's for the girlies Ethan it's for
the girl okay so so you're saying no
you're saying no I'm feeling like yeah I
if yeah I agree with Lena I don't know I
feel like wait you you gotta be a girl
to call oh another woman a [ __ ] so I
can't okay I got you I got you but so
you guys all seem to be in consensus I
think that's in poor form so [ __ ] I'm
laughing because you big man so can
Ethan ever say [ __ ] towards a woman is
the uh pull yes sir yeah okay all right
throwing it up and I mean as we know we
have a majority enough of the flock AB
inappropriate I'm not I can't I can't
vote because obviously I don't have I
don't know how to see the results though
Dan will tell us uh we're gonna put on
screen right over your face I'm
abstaining as a man I'm abstaining for
this and I encourage all men to abstain
for right vote so we're gonna come in
let me give it one more
one more interesting
I'm getting the B pass from our fans
interesting all right yeah there it is
what so I think I think to respect the
women here in the room I'm gonna have to
pass on saying that well that's that's
that's respectful of you so what what
could I I need to find a word that just
was just how vile she is bet you
um you know very famous but she gets on
stage in this really hideous outfit that
is wildly inappropriate and what
inappropriate for what what is she going
to church
right it's her show how's that
inappropriate I think she can make her
own rules on her she's so vile the
Smithsonian or the National Archives or
something actually allowed her you don't
even know it's from the Library of
Congress
you said it's from the Smithsonian you
[ __ ]
dumb [ __ ] weasel dude low life holy
[ __ ] and apparently the is it like the
Smithsonian or the National Archives or
something actually allowed her to be the
first person in the United States
history to play the crystal flute the
great Crystal flu the coveted Crystal
flute people have been lining up for
centuries to play the coveted Crystal
flute this thing has been sitting in a
drawer for like 80 years guaranteed yeah
it's like literally nobody cares about
the flute the course the flute of magic
it's rumored to give Eternal youth
people have been lining up for centuries
and this fat
this fat
scantily clown is getting to blow on it
it's a sacrilege to all Americans from
James Madison I mean this is just
desecration slave owners of America's
history and this just shows how much the
left is laughing at American history and
they wanted to put somebody like I can
only imagine what she when she spills
like a glass of milk this is just this
has ruined my day this is the worst
thing that's happened to me all year I
mean wasting milk like that is basically
spitting in the face of the hungry and
the destitute of this country for you to
spill milk like that is just is a
[ __ ] desecration Abomination she's
talking to her son like that or like
five-year-old
like lizzo up to be like oh yeah now
you've made history honey it's
disgusting it's depraved and I don't
care what anybody says that woman is
super unhealthy she is absolutely
um not a role model in any way shape or
form okay who are you to say all those
yeah keep talking fatty
and she is not oppressed so Ryan your
thoughts on this story when I first
watched the video
it came to mind the late Joan Rivers who
are you wearing I it was a disgusting
outfit and for them to give such a I
think it's kind of dope that she doesn't
give a [ __ ] and wears what she wants can
we see the guy that's talking piece of
History uh and she's the first one to
play it you know this glass flute
was an Abomination I mean there's no
words
or out there you know I mean there's
Millions who know how to play a flute
famous people too and you pick oh lizza
name some she is not famous yeah why
don't you name a few uh famous flautists
then he just described her
of all the famous flutists in the world
you pick lizzo of which I am a huge fan
and I know I can list off a dozen
flautists off the top of my head right
now ah it's just is it just the craziest
thing you've ever seen yeah
uh here she keeps going make fun of it
and to make it this laughing stock
he's on stage in this
in the appropriate outfit and you know
you know this and it's on purpose trying
to bring the Dignity of America's
founding into the absence
I a perfect like I said and an
encapsulation of the liberal left it
just wants to make everything that is
wonderful a mockery
a total mockery and this is the type of
individual and this is the type of
ideology that they want to teach kids I
think we need to sample this whenever
we're getting into like weird care and
[ __ ] Zach and you could just play that
in a low volume in the background you
got it it's like so perfect in public
school
concerned say we need to have better
role models than lizzo
they say that
oh yeah of course that's this is what he
looks like yeah so look at you know CRT
look at you know
you know saying I don't know if you saw
it was in El Paso where the teacher
basically comes out and says you know
don't judge someone just because they
want to have sex with a five-year-old
and don't no where where is this
conversation going what
are you did we stop with the did we
start with the flu
he's willing to sit in front of the
Washington Monument it's just a little
too sus for him a little gay bro to have
a phallic object behind him with that
pink sunset I felt worthless
Monument make you feel I felt gay I felt
that no like that's based on what they
told me
oh man but there's actually more I'm
sorry yeah there's more including our
favorite everyone's favorite Ben Shapiro
Matt Walsh uh both from the Same by the
way Matt Walsh Ben Shapiro
they work at the same org as Jordan
Peterson the most tolerant man alive
what Matt Walsh the guy you're going to
see talk about this and and Ben Shapiro
yeah Jordan Peterson just joined the
daily wire again he is of course the
most tolerant man alive
Matt Walsh does simply desecrating
American history just for the sake of it
I mean like like they might have first
of all they're wrong however you cut it
but like maybe if she had no training
and had no idea how to play a flute
their mind if he wasn't into this
argument like a famous musician she's a
classically trained flutist
you know
he quote tweeted someone saying it's the
nation's cap of this person was saying
it's cool he's the first ever to play
President James Madison's 1813 Crystal
flew courtesy of the library of COG we
were super amazing to see Mount Walsh
continues actually it's not just for the
sake of it there's a very clear Point
here to send the message that our
heritage and history are meaningless and
that nothing we love or care about has
any value
what does he mean by that because the
heritage is like that the guy was racist
right
and she's a black woman and that's he
thinks it's at some kind of deliberate
message which I wouldn't have no problem
with well that's the thing is anything
it's a good message unless we disagree
about slavery yes he wants slaves back
but that's the interesting thing is
they're the ones who brought it there
like we looked at all of the videos and
all like what lizzo had to say about it
and it was just this wholesome thing
promoting history like she didn't bring
up race at all at all yeah and it's like
they're telling on themselves a little
bit because they realize it's like the
implication is like oh this is a black
woman who 200 years ago would have been
owned by this man and here she is
playing his instrument his beloved
Crystal flute or whatever and wow yeah
and in my opinion that's actually pretty
cool yeah and like but they didn't but
that wasn't the message nobody said that
but you like you brought it there it is
a cool point right because we don't
agree with slavery
right question where Matt Walsh's
beliefs are yes exactly the Heritage
what did you mean by Heritage Matt
unpack that yeah
uh lizzo is morbidly obese very
interesting point
she she's that's interesting
fat fat man bad fat lady bad lizzo is
morbidly obese weirdo and a thong
twerking around on stage while playing
with a Priceless piece of American
History it's a flute you [ __ ] idiot
sitting in a time in a dark desk you
didn't know this thing existed that's a
level of care we're talking about also I
don't give a flying [ __ ] if it's an
honor for her that's not the point yeah
got it
this person tried to tell him she's a
classically trained flutist
he's like I don't give a [ __ ] it's about
the it's about the the
heritage
the intention he continues the intention
of our cultural Elites is always to
insult and humiliate that's the first
thing you must realize
okay
okay imagine how it feels to be owned by
another person uh crazy perhaps dude
these people are nuts and then he
continues on they are outright admitting
that this was done as a purposeful Act
of degradation racial retributions
against one of our founding fathers and
yet I still see some conservatives on
here being like lighten up everyone I
think it was kind of cool see this is
what I was getting at it they weren't
getting the juice that they wanted out
of this because even a lot of
conservatives were like
what the flute like what what what's the
flute like what are we even talking
about like what the flute what the flute
yeah I love that he goes I demand all
conservatives be outraged by this some
of you people are hopelessly obtuse and
I think there's any saving you at this
point sadly Ben Shapiro everyone's
favorite uh intellectual the lizzo flute
controversy is a perfect example of what
I have termed face tattoo phenomenon the
phenomenon whereby someone does
something deliberately controversial in
an attempt to draw attention and then
acts offended when you notice
um you know what's in do you know what's
you know what's intentionally
controversial
Ben Shapiro with a beard have you seen
this oh yeah what is happening there
let me see pulled that up you want to
talk about face tattoos like it's a rare
gift
for a man of his age to somehow look
worse with a [ __ ] beer bro no shot
that's real no that's not real
yeah he's trying to grow it out wet ass
p-word
no shot Is that real I think that one
might be
it's fine
just looks weird
yeah what an idiot uh he Contin daily
wire that's the one James Madison plays
James Madison's flute James Madison am I
a joke to you okay nice memes I mean
obviously yeah he oh he hates and owns
black people so certainly wouldn't be
happy with her playing the float he's
also been dead 200 years he also never
played it too that [ __ ] never
even cared enough to play the damn thing
he probably got and was like cool what
am I going to do with this I'm not a
flutist
the thing that is obvious what people
don't want to say is that they're this
is about humiliating white people there
it is about desecrating American history
and Heritage
when you see hear people say American
history they're literally talking about
slavery that's it when white people own
black people that's what you do when
you're a conqueror humiliate the
Conqueror if she wasn't like fat if she
was just said black
fit person how would they have spent
like spin it as like a problem I think
the fat is just an extra
an extra fun little topping for them I
just think they they have an excuse to
call her out on the obese without like
saying that they're all so mad about
other stuff well the same thing happens
with me right every every insult I get
starts with fat yeah uh you can always
spot a conservative guy because they're
the only men in America that look worse
with the beard right I was just saying
this is wild talk to you soon that's
such a funny point
so
um basically I think that's about it on
that one but yeah what do you think
pretty well stuff huh
there it is lizzo ladies and gentlemen a
desecration
yo people are asking us to talk about
Tucker Carlson exploding Milk porn but
what is that maybe we'll talk about it
next week or it's kind of old news at
this point it's not even in the dock
anymore but but anyway it's time to wrap
it up it is that time I want to remind
everybody that uh although there will
not be a episode on Monday because me
and healer are celebrating our 10th
wedding anniversary there will be an
episode on Tuesday for our beloved
members
see you next Tuesday episode two
it's a Members Only
podcast
uh to show appreciation for the people
that support us and then we will be back
this story they're on Wednesday oh oh
yeah I know that keep not getting the
chess story too maybe there'll be new
developments though next week also a
reminder there's a BTS going up today so
that members content is pretty much
popping as soon as this ends I will
publish it yeah and don't and guys if
you can't afford to be a member you know
nothing's changing here it's fine I
totally understand or you know but
you're still getting four episodes of
excellent H3 content every week that's
what it is
we're seeing if we can add more tickets
yeah they're looking into that for us um
if it is if it's gonna happen it's gonna
be a small amount but you know and we
might be able to squeeze out some more
seats into the venue somehow and um
people are uh uh last report that I got
There's 7 000 people on the way in
thousands yes uh which obviously we will
not be squeezing out seven thousand but
if you happen to be near the top of the
waiting list there may be you know
people would actually buy a live podcast
at the Greek
that's what I want to do I was like if 7
000 people are going to come let's do it
at the Greek but there's no shot I think
you know if if this goes well and we
want to do more live shows in the future
we should definitely ramp up to bigger
venues I I would my my thinking is to do
that slowly though yeah because this
will be a little pilot I could say
Dodger Stadium 50 000 because this is
the first one we've done in years this
is naturally going to have the big surge
of interest but if it becomes a regular
thing you know people are like maybe
I'll go to the next one I'll skip this
one and so by the way thank you to Carly
Egan for the gifted five Legends yeah so
um yeah I agree I think the next one
will be like 1500 and if that sells out
insane again then maybe we could move up
a little bit yep 1500 seems like a lot
though to me yeah well that'd be about
double of what that's what we're doing
now so
but yeah that roughly is the next kind
of like tier of venues that are around
in La so it would be somewhere around
there oh go somewhere bigger net force
of good thank you for the gifted there
we go legend
did I think uh
did I thank Alex uh Mendoza for the 50.
was there a message or that was another
donation or another yeah I did I did
read that one yeah thank you all the
gifted Subs are just you guys are so
cool
um
yeah 1500 seems like insane I'm still
skeptical if we can sell that out like I
don't know that's a [ __ ] insane you
guys
um but we'll see we'll keep doing it
it'll be fun we're gonna sell it out in
1500. no problem dude we sold 730
seconds yeah I mean it was extremely
fast and yeah I mean having a waiting
list of 7 000 gives you a decent but how
many of those people you think really
would buy a ticket or they're just like
yeah
I think easily 1500 out of that 7000
would I yeah I think we could sell 1500
I don't know Phil well we'll see
actually even less because it would just
be like 800 out of that 7 000 on top of
the ones that actually got tickets would
would fill up a 1500. yeah okay good
that'll be fun 1500 is a lot that'd be a
big crowd then that's a big crowd that'd
be that'd be crazy I have a feeling we
could sell out way more when it's so
much time ahead so people have time to
plan and stuff
for four or five thousand dude that's
insane because for us with the kids like
it's not really an option to travel and
do
the show like in different locations so
we're only going to be la
5 000 would be absolutely [ __ ] nuts
that's like a big ass show isn't it
that's like a rock star style and I'm
with love I think
I don't know
I mean the Greek I'm I'm afraid of
getting embarrassed and nobody calms
like fousey then everyone makes fun of
me forever
that's fine Rick's gonna be there guys
let's do what uh what they did for that
show and just have someone anonymously
calling a threat have someone bomb
threat all right kidding by the way
kidding by the way right make more magic
of the jokes there absolutely joke not
serious threats a joke a reference
actually to an event that happened in
real life it did happen
oh my God okay well we'll see you know
uh but I'm looking forward to to it it's
gonna be really fun
have a great weekend guys
have a great week happy 10th anniversary
let's go
congratulations guys
all right guys
um yeah have a great weekend we'll see
you guys on uh members on Tuesday
everyone else on Wednesday we'll have
another great
week of content coming up and uh hey God
bless keep pushing keep slamming you
know stay sub Primo
Primal
oh and remember guys
you know what's true what your best
memories are ahead of you or at least
some a lot I think for some people in
our age range
your best your best moments are ahead of
you
it's over the hill why are you squinting
like that you [ __ ] I just I'm just
wondering where this is going it kind of
just feels a little out of life there
you squint it was just
yourself wondering where you're going
here I'm saying that it's worth sticking
it out
there's so much to look forward to
you know sometimes you feel like
nothing's working out
hopeless
destitute just [ __ ] like why
but it's important to remember that your
best moments are
ahead of you over the hill I think
[Music]
um
Henry the 20 year old
that just got diagnosed should keep us
updated oh yeah
right
and uh The Best Is Yet To Come In the
words of uh Trump's
life
[Music]
can dream
that that's basically a more eloquent
way of expressing what I was trying to
yeah feeling inspired
all right y'all love you see you next
week
[Music]
s and gaps with all the guests you'll
see the best podcasts in the world take
it from me JC over chair HP baby we
podcasting now
you're watching next to the three